the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the atmosphere is electric and so is the
play at the superbed chess classic in
Bucharest Romania with crucial tour
points up for grabs players pressed for
any advantage they could find Fabiano
caruana came with amazing prep but Anish
giri avoided the danger and found the
necessary moves to make a draw the only
winner was John Christophe Duda who
defeated alireza farugia leaving caruana
in clear First It's the final round and
the title is on the line day nine of
Championship chess coming up next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the 2023 Superbad chess Classic held
here in Bucharest Romania it's been an
incredible event so far but it finally
comes down to this who's going to be
able to take the title home championship
and Final Round is about to unfold let's
go to the studio in St Louis and start
the action
we welcome you to the first stop on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of superbed Romania
we come to you live from the San Luis
chess club
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us to the championship round I'm
International Master Nazi Pai kids and
I'm here with Grandmaster yester 01. I
can't believe it the tournament's over a
championship round you know yes sir all
good things have to come to an end it's
true it's true hello everyone and
Welcome to our final round coverage talk
about an impactful final round my
goodness of the five games that we will
be watching today for could potentially
decide the outcome of first place Nancy
the honors and tell us about the current
standings all right let's take a look in
the final round Fabiano caruana has a
half point lead and then closely
following four players alireza fioruja
Wesley so Anish giri and Richard Robert
MBL our defending Champion is out of the
mix ride with 50 we have Maxima Sheila
grave and Jan Cristo of Duda and then
with three points we have
and let's remind everybody of the format
10 player round robin tournament with a
classical time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one
no draw offers allowed and the players
get one point for a win half for a draw
and zero for a loss
and not much of a schedule left left but
here we go right we have a final round
today
starting uh an hour early because of her
potential playoff scenario just remind
everybody what happens in case of a
playoff right if they're too
too game rapid match with 15 minute plus
10 second increment time control if
there's three or more players tied for
the first there'll be rapid round robin
with 10 minute and 5 Second increment
time control and it's still tied in that
case in case in that case we get an
Armageddon game with five minutes for
white four for black two second
increment from move 61 and black gets
draw outs you know some heart pounding
action dead ahead and a good morning VAR
uh nice to see you uh bright and early
in studio today and you have a number of
what-if scenarios take us through them
good morning guys yes there are five
players who can still win this
tournament Fabiano is in the lead he's
got the best chances but there are many
different scenarios let's take a look
for Fabiano
so if if Fabi wins he just simply wins
the tournament nobody can catch him so
that would be the you know what he would
like to do of course
so if Abby draws firusha saw or giri
Draw or lose Fabi wins the tournament
still
if Fabi loses firusha so and giridrow
Report actually is the winner of the
tournament
then this is firuja's last chance if
Fabi giri and so draw firusha wins play
off between firusha and Fabi
and we're gonna go to Romania to our
friend Grandmaster Christian chirilla
thanks VAR and welcome back chess fans
to uh the final and Championship day
here at the Superbad chess classic and
what an event we've had so far yesterday
that game between Duda and Ali Reza well
Ali Reza was trying to defend trying to
keep Pace with his co-leader going into
that round Fabiano but he was unable to
do so just a devastating loss for
alireza but today he has a good
opportunity with the white pieces to
potentially catch back with Fabiano
speaking of Fabiano as we entered this
final day he is the sole leader of the
event so how did he get to where he is
well he started off slowly with a couple
of draws in the first and second round
but after that bang bang in round three
and four victories with the white pieces
against Jana pomniashi and Maxim vashier
La Graf completely different games but
he got the job done and after that he
slowed down plus two is enough to have
him as the sole leader going into the
final round and you can see him right
now getting ready for his final match
the final battle with black pieces
against Richie Rapport speaking of
Richie and a few others as well who are
closely behind Fabiano only half a point
behind are firuja Wesley so Anish giri
and Richie Rapport who is playing
Fabiano but take a look at that all of
these players are having the white
pieces in today's round that is a golden
opportunity to put pressure on their
respective opponents and potentially try
to catch up with Fabiano and force a
playoffs guys we have amazing
action-packed chess coming from
Bucharest and I cannot wait to get the
game started back to you guys in savings
thank you Christian for that the
pairings indeed look very very good and
if you compare the number of decisive
games
percentage-wise this is what we
happiness we had seven white winds four
blackwinds which is quite impressive
right 29 draws so assuming just you know
making the assumption that Fabby worded
raw then of the remaining games you kind
of think there's a good chance that
somebody's gonna win that there's going
to be at least two players going into
that playoff scenario that you outlined
earlier so I don't know but it seems to
me that a playoff is in store we will
see as we're standing by but they're
fighting hard and what are they fighting
for right they're fighting for a lot of
money yep there is 350 000 price fund
for this event and the first place
winner is going to get one hundred
thousand dollars second place 65 000
their place 48 000. as you say very
handsome price funded 350 000 divided
all the way down to 10th and final
position gets ten thousand grantchester
appoints up for grabs if that be were to
win you you would get an additional
bonus of one grand chest or points the
players with the most grand Chester
points at the end of the tour gets a
hundred thousand dollars and there we
see a very very unfortunate World chess
champion dingler in is just thinking to
himself let me make a draw let me get
out of here let me go home let me
celebrate The Laurels of winning the
championship and forget about this event
he really has had it I think Nepal has
similar feelings exactly exactly and
that's when things can get really
dangerous because at the moment you kind
of like okay give up on the tournament
doesn't mean that your opponent has
given up a byrich by the way Richie
there on the left sharing a moment
listen to being good spirits exactly
exactly uh as uh we're expecting some
very interesting formidable I want to
say first move
uh persons who are going to come and
make the ceremonial first move and by
the way how does Richie and Fabby stack
up looks like Bobby has couple more wins
over windshield so Rachel won once lost
three times and they have six trusts
yeah a big decisive
percentage from there
rivalry of the 10 games played for been
decisive classical games yes very
important now Richie
interestingly for a player that we know
is very creative inventive and well
let's just call him daring he takes a
lot of risks and yet there he is
undefeated with a nice quiet plus one
giving himself a chance to win the
tournament clear first with a victory
can't wait to see what opening he
chooses today I know it won't be H3
I don't think it will be United
um
hmm bar jump in here if you were in
Richie shoes you you're white you know
you got a chance to win a hundred
thousand dollars clear first you're
white against Fabby where do you target
where is your
light it's it's not easy it's not easy
as we've seen this tournament fobby is
extremely well prepared but my idea
would be to try to just get a game even
if it's equal position something Fabi as
an analyze something obscure and Richie
is good at that so I don't think he's
gonna play some main lines against Fabi
I think he will try to avoid the theory
maybe get even some equal position
um maybe we will see some trampolski
London something like that that you know
he also helped Dingle it in with maybe
some analysis from that world
championship match uh something like
that to get a playable position
and for alireza I mean for him it's
awkward too he's playing his countrymen
MBL our defending Champion he will no
longer be Champion uh coming off a very
very very painful loss farrugia's line
score quite a different line score from
the one that you were showing of favi's
uh line score his line scores got donuts
uh on the bookends there he got three
wins in between those two Donuts in
round one and round eight can he make it
a complete roller coaster ride and take
down MBL in this final game that would
be
remarkable that must be a spectacular
guarantee a playoff with either Fabi or
one of the players with white pieces who
wins today exactly provided Fabby
doesn't win that's that's step one and
for farrugia's uh comeback
yeah and for Anish Gary another
player like Richie report rather quiet
but undefeated Wesley so quiet
undefeated if it's still in there with a
shout and nepo
much like Daniel are in let's get out of
here
as we get the public announcement of
this Championship round
[Music]
we have a
a lot of important guests today and I
will start with a lady for the lady
Andrea I will yes
and the world champion
last second advice I believe this is
Katelyn morrisonu a Roman oh party this
is Andrea Paul yes thank you partner
Romanian Economist and
she's been directed before
what a good Economist should do
this
foreign
[Music]
um
the vice president of the National
Liberty party
well this is for sure
what
no no no this is a chess created
I believe can't believe it
you see the artistic way
[Applause]
you could play any move you want you
know like just come on in oh
Romanian kickboxer oh boy maybe he can
play the chess box and match uh oh
Knight A3 no no no no no no the other
night
no no no no no what would you like me to
do indecisive oh yeah yeah yeah money
got most to choose from he is sure
having a tough side with this
now again Romanian kickboxer any movie
you want is fighting with me he was
having fun with it nice
[Applause]
oh thanks Derby here
[Music]
by the way for the players who have to
win with the white pieces you look
across the board there's no easy uh
points to be had I mean I don't care if
you're you're playing the wounded nepo
or not I mean that's not a gimme
now in this type of events there
absolutely
to us in the making is really well
possible
[Applause]
for our last round tournament to get
underway I do want to just give a shout
out to the remaining of organizers
everything that I've seen so far from
the playing Hall to well just
everything about the organization has
been first class
and so we have Michael korsakovski
coming out to make you seem to be late
to the playing huh he wanted to get in
the first move forward
yeah one of the driving forces behind
the whole grandchester or classic a big
shout out to Michael for all of his
efforts and again I just wanted to say
to the Romanian organizers thank you big
thank you for such a wonderful event
truly they they really and the players
and the interviews have said everything
has been first class they've really
enjoyed the event as have we
they're about to start their games are
we actually going to see a lot of C4
moves
London yeah I can see what you're saying
there for something a little bit offbeat
but trying to get a long game a long
fight keep keep
the pressure on Fabi
not an easy task not an easy task that
is true
the last round players can be a little
more nervous because so much is on the
line yeah but all of them are so
experienced they've all been in similar
situations before
so I don't think these players are as
nervous as I would be yes exactly
um the one hour earlier start VAR jump
on that for a second I think we are
creatures of schedules uh Grandmasters
like you know very clear clear schedules
this extra one this earlier one hour
start how does it impact the players
um I don't think it impacts them that
much but me just they just need to make
some adjustments and for the past eight
days they probably had some kind of
routine that they were following at
least that's what I tried to do during
the tournaments and they just maybe had
to just wake up a little bit early and
just adjust their preparation a little
bit
so you don't think it's a big impact I'm
not not a big one yeah if it's like we
changed around from afternoon to a
morning sometimes that happens to you
yes that that's I know the players don't
like that players with riots yeah
it was very often that vikon say the
traditional Tata steel started at one
and then would turn to 11 in the morning
room that was a riotous occasion here we
have somebody uh interesting I believe
what is this could be Sebastian producer
vice president of National Liberty party
there you go well Sebastian's the E4
player like our Economist you know the
National Liberty party thank you
Sebastian
[Applause]
we had quite a number of first moves and
again everyone this today yeah
yeah including Michael korsakovski and
the grand old man of Romanian chess
flooring Giorgio who uh
for a number of years was in the world's
top 10 players so and also a Grandmaster
yes yes
um
top player from the movie
I don't think he became a candidate but
I could easily stay corrected on that
score
players can't wait to start the game and
again Richie is left seat the pawn on C4
we saw earlier that Daniel dioc did not
like that admonished as a take back and
play it yourself
said Daniel Mary Richie
is leaving it on the board yes
and there we go
looks like yep
he goes
intriguing that he left it on the board
that long and then allowed the move loud
Fabi to think about his first exactly uh
England I mean we understand that the
players that at the very very top or
ambidextrous they can play Eve E4 D4 C4
Knight F3 on their first moves
um
a little bit surprise for you VAR that
Richie in this all-important
Championship round played one C4 a
little bit very little bit but again it
depends on his preparation uh I was
expecting more like the food Knight
after Bishop before this type of
openings yeah London for example but I
guess C4 is also very interesting there
are many different type of positions you
can get and just just keep many pieces
on the board avoid a lot of the trades
and just get something playable with
lots of pieces on the board guys we have
at least one very very exciting open and
in game and if Theory against
the Anisha we have we have Sicilian on
the
boat didn't play the Russian defense and
inviting even especnikov
with his move order of Knight C6 that is
a very very very big surprise and the
players are going for espejnikov because
nepo has been playing so successfully
the Russian defense with E5 and Knight
F6 on moves one and two
yeah really really stunning and again
he's inviting especially but in this
particular move order of this vashnikov
for example after Bishop F4
E5 Bishop G5 the big difference
is that
white is not given the option of Knight
D5 as Fabi played in his world
championship match against
um
Magnus and instead they have to go after
A6 either Bishop takes F6 or Knight A3
Knight A3 immediately B5 Knight D5 and
Bishop E7 and again you know like oh boy
oh boy the main line is so deep oh
there's so so much Theory here oh
they're truly the key decision for an
initial b if he's gonna play C3 or C4s
version exactly as we go down and let's
just check in once again on the you know
four games here's the uh
um petrol
uh Knight C3 takes by Wesley on the
white side again white struggling to
really show advantage
in this ancient defense
Ali Reza versus MBL Queen's Gambit
accepted uh with a little twist of a
move Rook okay what do you want
not the most common move I've seen Queen
not the most offensive either uh
excuse me Christian who has a guest for
us in Bucharest
thanks guys yes we are with Sebastian
borduja the minister of digitalization
here in the Romanian government
Sebastian first of all welcome to the
show Welcome to the super bachelor's
classic tell us about your first
impressions of the tournament I love the
energy I think it's absolutely wonderful
everybody's coming together and we're
very proud and honored to host this
amazing event in Bucharest again and I
saw a lot of smiling faces a lot of
anticipation before this important day I
think it's the final day yes and so the
championship round Championship round
and I was very honored to to do the
first move which I've done last year as
well so thank you for having me back
tell us a bit about your work as the
minister of digitalization
well it's very exciting I like to say
that I'm the luckiest minister of the
whole government I'm certainly the
youngest I'm 39 almost but uh I'm the
luckiest because I often interact with
the smartest people that Romania has
that are researchers innovators experts
in digital transformation in itnc
generally the country has amazing Minds
in I.T I think we're famous not just for
uh gymnastics and and Dracula and
vampires but also for a very smart I.T
people and every day I interact with
them we're basically in the middle of a
digital Revolution as I like to call it
and we're taking our government digital
we're providing more and more Public
Services entirely in the digital
environment as well as helping to
educate the young people in in what it
means to to be in the new digital
economy and be competitive we had our
own digital Revolution as well in 97
when Gary Kasparov lost his match
against deep blue at the beginning we
were a bit afraid to embrace this new
technology But as time of passed we
started welcoming it do you see any
similarities between our story and your
story in the real world yeah I mean I
think you know playing chess it opens up
your mind and you see new possibilities
all the time you have to adapt
dynamically it's the world we live in
and uh certainly you see the the pace of
technological change has never been
faster there's the theory called the the
knowledge curve and apparently uh you
know around 1945 our the knowledge that
Humanity had doubled every 25 years I
think it was today it doubles every 12
hours so you know with the event of AI
and virtual reality and all the new
tools that that are now available really
to anybody in the world
just the pace of change is is tremendous
and do you see the Romanians embracing
this change as well I do and I'm very
happy about it because I think that you
cannot Advance your economy or country
unless you take everybody with you
there's something called the digital gap
which is a risk in that those who are
less fortunate poorer have less access
to education and also have less access
to technology so the risk in this
process is that they just get left
further behind and inequality grows so
you know special measures are needed and
policies to ensure that those who don't
have uh all the opportunities that that
other members of society have have
access to these programs to digital
skills and in fact I think it can be a
way for them to catch up faster and it
can be a way for a country like Romania
to catch up faster to Western Europe and
to the United States Sebastian I think
you're doing great work thank you very
much for joining us and all deciding to
be here and good luck to all those
competing thank you guys back to you
thank you uh Sebastian thank you
Christian indeed it just feels at times
especially in the world of Chess that
our knowledge of Chester not doubles
every 12 hours but uh yeah we're
learning uh each and every uh day uh the
computers are just remarkable I just
want to turn our attention to the uh all
French derby with this move rookie won
because that is a a new move for me I
played the Queen's Gambit accepted my
whole life nobody ever played rookie one
against me feels a little soft and after
Bishop B7 takes takes sort of like white
snuck in this Tempo rookie one trading
Queens going into this ending is not
supposed to be much but in truth The
Rook is a little bit better on E1 in
these positions but the really big news
Anish Gary versus netball I want to send
that over to varusian if you don't mind
VAR that moved Knight A3 to B1
news for me
yes yes a very interesting prep uh by
Anish the move has been played before
but not not recently let's take a look
at some of the options how the game can
develop after this move here in my
database I have about 50 50 games in
this position so Bishop E7 played and
the almost every game 50 games played
was played by Bishop takes F6
taking the night Bishop takes back and
now before you play the move Knight D5
you want to insert this move A4 first
try to create some light Square
weaknesses and now before
you play the move 95 now
and black has some options here castling
is the main move you can also play the
move Bishop G5 we can go a few more
moves for example just Castle to see how
white can develop here you have the move
Knight D2 then put the Knight on C4 you
can also play the move Bishop C4 in this
position both moves are prepared moves
here for the engine so here actually you
don't want to keep the bishop too much
on F6 you just put a bishop on G5 here
and now you have it on this active
diagonal now in Castle
we continue and black has a few options
here A5 is a possibility to try to
protect this Pawn because after that you
have some ideas like 97 try to exchange
the Knight so position is very very
slightly better for white white can
continue to play Queen D3 perhaps put
the Rook on D1 then get the Knight on D2
and B3 very very slight Edge in this
position and we see the move A4 played
by Anish so he's definitely in prep at
the moment
the lifetime score between these two
Gladiators I thought that would have
more games between each other yeah the
three and three uh wins and losses seems
okay but at 16 draws and that was that
would match up with my expectations as
well
and let's jump back to Bucharest with
Christian
thanks Yaz yeah I just want to give you
a quick little story from the playing
Hall uh as the players were getting
ready to start the games and they were
all at uh on in their seats
um Richie report and Fabiano caruana was
trying to understand their energy and
um I did discuss uh the beginning of the
game or at least the potential beginning
of the game with Fabiano's second and I
asked him hey what do you guys expect
for a first move and he Shrugged his
shoulders and he didn't say anything and
I said I think rich is going to go with
one E4 he said no no no no there's no
way he's going to play one E4 he played
one C4 so they were definitely right
that kind of points the fact that most
likely they were ready for this type of
ideas and in fact just a couple of days
ago we did discuss uh all of us all
three of us this idea with E4 for white
the one that we see in the position
right now and Fabio was saying that this
bishop to C5 just kills this idea with
E4 so he's aware aware of what he needs
to do he's probably very comfortable
he's been trying to crack the the the
the the black side of the Reversed
English for quite a while he's a C4
player as well Fabi that is so he is
definitely aware of what the situation
looks like in this particular variation
and let's take a look at what happened
Bishop to B4 take take on e4 yes this is
the big and probably most theoretical
variation in this line Fabi has some
experience he played it against uh
Magnus Carlson in fact in the grand
Swiss a few years back I don't remember
exactly the year but he did play it um
he has experience with the black pieces
I'm expecting him to know what he's
doing in this position quite well and by
the way ding also played this against
nepo in the world championship match so
we see some you know similarities
connections between the repertoires of
dingly Wren and Richie Rapport for good
reason Richie has been the second of of
dingley ran for for some time now and
during the world championship match so
quite an interesting early development
from Bucharest guys back to you in the
studio thank you Christian and I have to
say uh and Nancy you've been leading a
Charmed life I've been waiting for it to
happen and it had to happen in the
championship round but the commentators
curse you got hit with the commentator's
curse and I refer of course to the game
uh between a niche and Napo because you
said
well Anish has got to decide whether
he's going to play C3 or C4 and of
course the moment you make a declarative
sentence like that he's got to decide
between C3 and C4 he of course he plays
Knight D1 and avoid C3 and C4 the
theoretical lines that you were uh about
to discuss and we're catching up with
the players a A4 I think B4 is pretty
much the only move night jumps and
instead of the night being on A3 which
as you say sometimes you play C4
sometimes and reroutes here we see the
pathways a little bit more clear on the
other hand black could potentially just
put his Knight on the D4 square and say
hey you got squares that got squares
isn't life wonderful let's jump back to
the game of Richie for just a moment and
I'll ask you VAR uh this this particular
line of the English with E4 has become
popular and why is that is white
statistically score ring well from this
position let's check actually this exact
position I have 86 games played in my
database I'm a little bit surprised that
Fabi is thinking right now because uh if
he was familiar with you very confident
he should just play there are two
options he has here one is uh Bishop two
a A5 you can play here in Bishop E7
these are the two options here Bishop A5
by far the most popular move 69 games I
have in this position uh a black is
doing really well here 80 percent after
the mubish bay 5 according to the
database I'm using Bishop E7 is another
move that black does uh fine we did is
50 so he's trying to decide between
these two moves here I will show you how
the theory develops after this move so
if you play the move Bishop A5 here
white has few options here you can play
uh Bishop F4 is the most popular move
most likely we're going to see that
Bishop B2 is another idea but they're
even moves like Bishop A3 played before
in this position but Bishop A4 the main
move let's say you Castle
and here the main idea in this position
is black really wants to play D6 quickly
and put pressure after okay so the key
move in this position is the long Castle
here yeah it doesn't look very natural
but that's what you're doing now you put
pressure on the D file here and we see
Carlson played this against Fabiano in
2019 nepo against aronian and uh many
many other top games here in this
position so I have 34 games in the
database right now Queen E7 is the main
move the idea to bring the queen to A3
and you play this move King E2
King B2 controlling the A3 squash
and uh
yeah so it's very very sharp position
here so we'll see if Aviano is going to
play Bishop A5 or Bishop B7 exactly and
let's jump to Romania as Christian is
with Michael korsakovski
thank you Yasser yes we are indeed with
the executive director of the grand
Chester and one of the masterminds
behind the grandchester Michael
korsarkowski Michael first of all
welcome to the show welcome back to the
studio from inside the organization how
did this tournament uh look for you well
as always uh torment from inside looks
different than from outside but I do
believe that it went very well uh last
round it's exciting we're definitely
going to have clear winner no matter
what and the field is very strong
probably the strongest field in
Bucharest at least and one of the
strongest the grunchiest tour speak
about that because we had a lot of
Fighting Chess in this tournament as
well almost 30 percent of the games were
decisive
um how did you enjoy this uh fighting
shot between these great players well
first of all classical cheers is not
dead right it's not that so that's
number one and number two uh these guys
you know want to fight
regardless of the color of pieces and
and we saw this so there are even some
draws were very well played and they
were very exciting yeah speaking about
the grandchester and the upcoming events
I believe you have some news breaking
news for us to share well uh
we have actually uh no breaking breaking
news uh we are going to Warsaw tomorrow
everyone will be flying or somebody who
will join us there will come a little
bit later uh world champion Dean
clearing uh after he won World
Championship match he contacted and
asked if we can uh I love him of uh the
tournament in Warsaw so he was eager to
come to Bucharest he even announced a
couple of times during press conferences
during his world championship match
regardless of the outcome
but he asked that he needs he feels some
fatigue and
wants to recuperate but he will continue
afterwards so we replace him with
American Grandmaster livon aronen that's
not a bad replacement at all yeah not at
all not at all such an exciting player
we have Levon aronian coming but we also
have one Magnus Carlson coming and
joining us I just wanted to say that you
know I don't underestimate the number
one in the world Magnus Carlson who will
be playing in warsa and Zagreb yes and
we were looking forward to seeing the
former world champion and the new world
champion we will not see them in Warsaw
but we will see them in Zagreb is that
correct I I'm not sure about that we
might not see see them playing against
each other but they are both on the tour
absolutely absolutely Michael thank you
very much for joining us exciting news
and we'll be seeing you in a couple of
days in Warsaw yes and maybe I will have
some breaking news from Warsaw too
looking forward to that guys back to you
in the studio thank you uh for that yes
dingler and we're skipping uh Poland
being replaced by levonne irony not
completely unexpected nice to see Lavon
yes who by the way
when I think about the grand chess tour
had always been one of the players of
the grand Chesterfield so it's it's
coming back you know but it's nice to
see him coming back certainly ding will
be picking up the pace uh with Zagreb
and the Saint Louis he'll get in his uh
tournaments uh just uh for sure
just going around the horn a bit uh just
checking the various games I wanted to
say about Richie's game that Bishop A5
one of uh the main theoretical moves uh
Bishop Bishop E7 Bishop A5 uh the move
Bishop A5 when it did come it came late
let's put it like that and it was
um a bit of a surprise for us because
Fabi uh usually his prep is so very good
VAR and you were mentioning Bishop F4
castles
castles long and of ultra sharp position
arrives on the board after Queen E7 and
uh King B2 the first move when I see the
move go when I see the move Bishop A5
the first move that catches my eye is
when The Bishop's away from the G7 Pawn
I'm really attracted to the move Queen
G3 please Castle
and make my day because I have Bishop H6
on my agenda right like an at least an
exchange yeah I mean you can toss in
Bishop takes C3 check but that's going
to cost you a piece by the time you
defend the threat of meat in one oops
there it goes is there Bishop takes E5
after King day one
right here Bishop takes E5 oh my gosh
maybe you're right I didn't see oh nice
uh that's quite the shot because
then I end up oh my gosh good morning
okay uh maybe that answers the question
why Queen G3 is not so threatening that
you can just castle and challenge white
to play the move Bishop H6 which may
explain but what comes to my mind of
Triple Two A5 is Bishop A3 to delay
Black's Castle yes I am absolutely with
you 100 I saw the move Queen G5 and I
couldn't find a good answer for white I
thought Queen G5
um
gosh darn it and I can't Castle too and
I can't easily defend if I with Queen E4
because then C3 hangs as well precisely
so that was why Bishop F4 ended up being
the most popular move Jump Right In Here
on this one bar first of all how long
did Fabi spend on the Move Bishop A5 and
do you think he was just trying to
recall all of his prep I think so he
spent about seven minutes and we know if
Bobby knows the moves he just plays so
quickly yesterday we saw finishing the
game with Anish and gaining more time on
the clock so he took some time trying to
maybe remember the lines and decide
between the move Bishop E7 back or
Bishop A5 but after uh after a few
minutes of think he played the move
Bishop A5 there's some very interesting
lines I want to show you you were
looking at the move Bishop A3 for
example there is a very cool idea there
let me show you here so if you play the
mubish bay 3 here to prevent uh castles
to prevent castling here here black
actually has to find pretty much the
only move here otherwise it's in really
really big trouble here because if you
manage to get the bishop out and Castle
this king is just simply stuck here and
the only move here is D6 in this
position because this move Queen G5
which looks very natural runs into a big
big problem here unexpected move H4
attacking the queen and you capture the
pawn on a fire but it's actually going
to backfire pretty badly because after
the move King D2 now you're threatening
to move rookie one and the king is still
stuck only one and this is actually a
winning position Queen D4 check King C2
now the queen is under attack and you
can play the move Queen E5 just to
prevent The Rook from coming to E1 you
don't have to move Bishop D3 yet because
the C3
but you can play the move Rook D1 even
in this position
and now a very strong threat Rook D5 and
this is just a winning position for
white so Bishop A3 is a move H4 yes but
the move D6 looks like uh just simply
equalizes the game because
if you take on these six now black will
be very happy to cancel and now the play
the move rookie a check in fact white
king could be in trouble here so you
have to play a long castle and black is
absolutely fine here but uh Bishop F4
was played instead of Bishop battery
because likely uh the Richard knows that
D6 is just equalizing and now
castles and long Castle this was also
played in uh I think I believe last
year's singfield Cup Tournament between
Hans Niemann and chakri Arma made out of
this position and Hans Hans won that
game and uh Queen E7 is the main main
move in this position Rook B8 is played
a couple of times as well here so let's
take a look after Rook B8
so nepo aronian white one in this
position so you can play Queen E3 is one
option you also have the move King B2
here most of the time in this positions
you can have to play the move King B2
wins once the queen is already only
seven to prevent the move Queen A3 here
we do have Queen E7 on the board by the
way group B8 secondary move Queen E7 by
Fabi yeah so 28 games in my database and
every game actually continued after the
move King B2 just to prevent the move
Queen A3 and Fabi has already played
this with the black pieces I guess
against Magnus yes okay Magnus and 2019
there is a game between Magnus and Fabi
and that game ended in a draw and we're
still following the game of Hans Neiman
versus Muhammad yarov these are the two
high-profile games in this position and
if you continue King B2 for a second
just go ahead and show us the most
theoretically trodden path group B8 is
the move that played in every game here
and here where we see some options here
for white you have the move Queen E3
play 25 times there's a bishop D3 move
play three times and the move Rook D5
let's let's go with the main line Queen
E3
and here now black has more options B5
is a possibility again a very logical
move because you put the Rook on bed you
want to try to open up the position and
just try to Checkmate while it's King
but it's not easy it's not easy to
attack the King on B2 Bishop B6 is
another possibility but let's look at
the move B5 because this might happen I
think B5
and here you have two options you can
take on P5 but also you can play the
move C5 just try to keep the position
closed and B4 black wants to open up the
position and of course when the move
before display you need the smooth C4
absolutely to keep it close you keep
that B file close otherwise Rook will be
very very active here and uh Bishop B7
can be played B3 is another alternative
to sacrifice a pawn uh in fact if you
capture I think the bishop B4 is is a
very good move and then you're gonna
pick up the pawn but why it actually
says no I just play A3 just to cover the
B4 square and now this B file is blocked
it's very hard to get to wise King and
white wants to play the move Bishop D3
H4 perhaps Rook H3 Rook G3 and just try
to organize a quick attack here because
black doesn't have too many Defenders
around so if attack starts it's gonna be
very difficult to defend because you
have no PC that will help your king
thank you for that for we have some nice
photos of some serious chess fans love
the bow ties by the way I mean all
dressed up yeah exactly exactly now
they're saying to themselves why doesn't
he play the bishop sacrifice
there you go very very very cute indeed
and by the way uh here we are in the
final run and I want to give a big shout
out just as the organizers but also to
our viewers thank you so much for uh
joining us and telling your friends
where you've been hanging out but most
especially for your tweets and uh
challenging the panel we appreciate all
your questions and you can send us more
uh on Twitter using hashtag Superbad
chess classic or you can tag Ranch and
store and if you're watching us on
YouTube or twitch feel free to send us
your questions on St Louis chess club
Channel absolutely and again we really
do encourage you to keep us on our toes
as we are in the last round with so much
at stake big big uh
game going on here uh for a second here
now see this this these this position is
very awkward for both sides that whole
meeting B5 with C5 meeting D4 was SC for
meeting D3 with A3 those are some
highfalutin moves I see the move Rook B8
and I say okay I get it you want to play
B5
and I'm thinking to myself I can shut
that down and I can shut it down in a
very nice way I would love to play
Bishop D3 Queen E4 get in my threats
especially if I can go H4 and you know
get to Black's King but because I
respect the fact that my king is a
little weak you know I'd love to start
with the move Rook D5 first of all I'm
taking away B5 I'm doing it with a gain
of tempo and I'm thinking in my mind's
eye if I could
stop black for just a sec get in Bishop
D3 get in Queen E4 I'm gold
why what what it looks good to me too
yeah you know I mean get in your shots
while uh they're Rook D5 you think we
could see B6
possibly B6 first threatening Bishop B7
right and then I was thinking okay you
want to sacrifice yeah well it's not my
pieces of course I want to sacrifice so
I was thinking Bishop B7 right
I was thinking Queen E4
okay again this is a kind of a strange
line sinking
G6 G6 right now in my mind's eye I'm not
frightened of Bishop takes it's sort of
like go ahead make my day I again these
aren't my pieces I can throw them out I
can show you know my my bravery my my
courage uh but boy if I was on the black
side winning an exchange with an offside
Bishop on A5 I'd be a little bit
frightened I would feel a bit worried as
well yeah but of course if Fabi has
already seen this position which we
assume he has he's familiar with this
attack said why it can throw it contract
right away and I'm sure he knows how to
equalize very precisely well let me put
the question to varvar Rook D5 looks
like a very tempting move for white
yes I was actually putting the moves in
when you guys were analyzing that time
it looked uh very very dangerous for
black but somehow that final position
block is doing really well here I will
show you uh why here Rook D5 only played
two times here and I wasn't familiar
with the players who played that game so
but let's take a look uh at that line
that you guys were analyzing so Rook D5
very logical move try to attack the the
bishop and uh B6
makes a lot of sense to try to play
Bishop B7
and Bishop D3 I think you were looking
at yes Bishop B7 Queen E4 Queen H3 is a
better move
because you're threatening uh on H7 and
also the D7 Pawn but
Black is Black is still fine after Queen
H3 there is G6 only move you actually
capture the pawn Rook 2 D7 and then
Queen C5
comes in now hitting the pawn on F2 and
at this point this pawns are going to
start to be very vulnerable you can try
to play the move Queen E3 just to
consolidate but then you're dropping the
G2 Pawn in position it's going to be
more or less equal dish but if you play
the move Queen E4 trying to threaten a
Checkmate G6 comes in and let's say you
go for the all-out attack this move is
very important B5 immediately looking
for a strong control play along the B
file here I was trying to stop that
movie you can't allow the capture
because then Bishop D5 is going to be
devastating opening up the B file so you
need to take back with this Pawn but now
Queen E6 comes in again it's you're not
really interested in taking this Rook
for a long time now you just want to win
it to win a full row here and if you
play the move Bishop C4
now to defend them you have Bishop takes
D5 and Bishop takes D5 The Rook B5 check
and after Queen takes D5 you will
exchange and pick up the pawn on B5 and
you're up of full exchange here exactly
so uh there is a move C4 in this
position
but again you're a little bit stretching
the position here a lot and black has a
very strong counter play with A6 just
opening up the position here and tactics
gonna work out uh well for black at in
this position
I don't doubt it at all for those of you
who are joining us late uh first of all
welcome to the show and we went through
a number of what ifs now see right if
you win today he wins the tournament
clear first that's pretty simple and a
hundred thousand dollars and a very nice
payday yeah and if puppy draws then
firosha saw or giri if they draw or lose
San Fabi still wins the tournament he's
just hoping nobody wins but if Bobby
loses and firoza and giridra then Robert
wins the tournament in clear first all
by himself
and uh from uh the players just behind
Fabi they're they're all rooting for
Richard uh step number one and they're
rooting for themselves step number two I
want to uh take us back to firusha MBL
game so you know in the opening we're
taught to develop our pieces move
forward yes yeah it's very good alireza
has chosen different path
he moved the bishop back to F1 and
Knight F3 to D2 right which is all
temporary I understand but it's still
unusual to see uh to say the least it's
unusual and I always had this attitude
whenever my opponent was retreating
go further go further backwards it looks
bizarre yeah exactly it looks very
bizarre to me uh
what can I say I mean a very very
unusual uh approach very different
approach than anything I've seen I mean
again I played Queen Gambit accepted
much of my career I don't think anybody
ever chose this setup with Bishop as you
say voluntarily retreating the bishop on
a C4 not waiting for B5 but voluntarily
retreating the bishop and then you know
everybody usually develops this night
first whether it goes to D2 and B3 or
something like that but this is
wow uh we're on new territory uh very
early in a ancient
opening I'm I'm a little bit perplexed
but is this engine approved is this what
uh the latest and greatest in Queens
Gambit accepted theory has has brought
us uh VAR not really this is also very
very rare and I think they just wanted
to get out of the theory I'm a little
bit surprised that alireza is choosing
such a quiet line to play in a must-win
game and we know that mvl is a great end
game player and I just don't see how
you're really gonna outplay such a
strong player in a in a position like
this because you really don't have
anything you don't have a leading
development and I also play a lot of
this endgame Syosset like you with from
the white side but at least in those
positions I try to have you know A3
before Bishop is already on B2 the
Knight goes on C4 some ideas like this
but let's analyze a little bit the
current position here and I will show
you where uh they sort of deviated from
the main Theory so if we go back to this
position so A6 rookie rookie one is not
the most popular move already in this
position you have Bishop B3 as the main
line you have DTX C5 Queen E2 A4 these
are all the most popular moves here so
rookie one is already a little bit rare
and here usually after this move rookie
one black plays the move Knight C6 and
there is some Theory after this but he
plays another move Bishop E7 now mvl
himself played very rare mobish B7 now
we have only four games in a database in
my database at least after this mobishop
p7 and E4 is the move that most people
try to play here and I think this move
makes a lot of sense after the move
rookie won and I would have liked to see
firosha go for this because this gives
the control of the center then you get
your night out the bishop on G5 and you
have an interesting position where you
have attacking chances okay perhaps
there is a B5 move in this position you
play Bishop B3 but even a position like
this I think it's not bad to get in a
position where you're trying to play for
a win black has some Queen side majority
but you have a nice control of the
center of course C4 move it's not
necessary but it would lead to some
interesting positions here but after
Bishop E7 he played
D takes C5 now going to this end game
and here the move Bishop F1 played it's
possible he maybe analyze this guys
because this is the best move according
to the engine here the point is to try
to get this C4 Square for the Knight so
Bishop F1 played King E7 and now Knight
fd2 not really developing this Knight he
is trying to keep these options open
maybe this knife will go to C3 later so
Knight fd2 unexpected move this is sort
of the new position and Bishop D7 played
by mvl the idea is sometimes you want to
play the more Bishop B5 exchange this
Bishops even you'll have those weak
pawns but you will get a file here at
the moment I don't see any advantage
here perhaps he will play the move
Knight B5 attacking the bishop D3 and
now black needs to decide where to put
this bishop here you have a few options
here Bishop D6 or Bishop A7 Bishop Bay 7
is the recommended move try to keep the
control of the C5 square and now Bishop
D2 threading Bishop B4 check so you
definitely don't want to allow that so
Knight C6 and now you have to waste
another Tempo because this definitely
this Rook is not well placed here you
need this Rook on a d file or on a C
file so you have to play this move and
after Rook HC I I don't see much
I don't see how white can really get an
advantage here now Bishop E1 is
recommended move to try to get the
Knight on D2 so it will be a long game
definitely I don't think alireza is
going to just trade pieces and make a
draw he's going to try to play this but
uh will be very very hard to get
anything real going here against nvl all
extremely extremely sophisticated those
moves of
wow a knight F3 to D2 uh very very
subtle I wanted to jump to something a
little bit more direct something that we
could really understand and that is the
game between Anish Gary and nepo again
espashnikov
very popular opening B7 B5
essentially everybody and his brother
has played two moves Bishop takes F6 as
well as Knight to D5 here Knight B1
seems to be a little bit of the latest
wrinkle and the difference is that this
Knight is now now that we've already
provoked the move before we've got
control over the C4 square and maybe our
minor pieces can land there excellent
okay but from Black's point of view hey
he's got the two Bishops he's got pretty
nice development and what do we love
about the opening uh safe King safe King
safe King Black's King is very safe
after the move castles castles Bishop G5
just sidestepping ideas of Knight takes
F6 and retaining the two Bishops but
more importantly
this move
prepping uh F7 F5 and you don't want any
accidents to occur but
and I see I'm a pond Grabber I mean I'm
looking at that A6 pawn and I'm saying
is that a cookie that I can get away
with uh why am I attracted to the move
Bishop takes A6 yes because I'm at uh
I'm winning a pawn but I also it comes
with a threat it's not just a pawn but
it's also a threat of Bishop the B7 and
what's sweet about capturing the a pawn
is it does give me a past Pawn now I do
appreciate the fact that well my queen
and Bishop aren't so coordinated I could
easily fall victim to a very powerful
counter-attack
your thoughts about grabbing the pond I
I see it's a novelty by the way people
do not grab that pond which is a shame
you know I used to play fashion club for
a couple years but you like pieces yes
and I've definitely never faced night to
be one right that's definitely new to me
but uh never developed pieces the
typical swashnika way sure Bishop E6
Bishop G5 those are all very common
moves right so my answer to Bishop A6 I
think the logical move Knight D4
followed followed by F5 should be a
fantastic conversation for black exactly
and I wouldn't
dispute that in any uh way that that
that is what black loves to do by the
way again they're head-to-head uh very
close 3-3 with four draws we kind of
would have expected to see a 10 like is
it 14 draws uh to sit there and say
these two players have sixty percent
decisive games between them two are very
solid players yeah right like what what
what uh that's pretty remarkable but I
like what you suggested there for nepo
Bishop takes A6 uh you know your your
queen side is getting eviscerated Knight
takes B4 that's the pawn number two but
when you look at that
F5 you sort of say well you know there's
not a lot of uh protection I want to say
with the white king and uh not too many
players want to be so fiercely attacked
as this situation allows black or just
two pawns not just for two fonts we want
uh some safety a game that well
truthfully uh these two players dingler
in versus
I've not been so successful
but I can't help but mention
that well
this brings a wry smile to my face
because
to the right of us here in studio at St
Louis chess club and Scholastic Center
there's a poster of the match carp off
Sarah one this is really really cool now
this Queen's Indian physician was like
one of the most discussed uh tavias of
the time and I knew that that if I was
going to play against Anatoly karpo that
this is something that could come up on
my board and I had prepared
a pawn sacrifice
the very Pawn sacrifice that is
appearing on this board
and we got to this position in the match
and this
something about these world champions uh
halia picked up something I I I I gave
them an indication like please please
please please take the pawn and he
demurred he deferred he did not go into
this variation and catching up with the
players
uh this is all the prep that I had
wanted and I had more or less stopped I
want to say here I don't think that was
my number one move in the position Queen
C4 I may have wanted to play Queen G
form not 100 sure no the reason I was
thinking of Queen I'm sure you can
remember your prep from years ago I
can't remember what I prepped last month
well I would love to say that I would
remember if it's the board as a
commentator I I think my prep was Queen
G4 just because uh I'm a pond grubber as
I mentioned numerous times give me back
my Pawn but Queen C4 and the players uh
like boy have they been racing to this
position and again in different
circumstances this might be our Marquee
game maybe because this is exciting
stuff uh far Jump Right In and tell me
what the latest uh theoretical
dispute is yeah let's discuss this first
here definitely uh diac is trying to go
for a win he's just not giving a world
championship a world champion any easy
game here definitely trying to I like
this position for white there's lots of
Dynamics but it's very very concrete
here let's first check uh what he can do
here after this move Knight A5 the queen
is under attack so you can Retreat Queen
E2 or queen queen C1 is actually another
idea here I have 18 games played with
the move Queen E2 in this position looks
like this is the main move a couple of
grand Masters games not not too many
very high profile games here so let's so
let's check the queen E2 move first
because you want to keep an eye on the
E5 Pawn here Rook fe8 will be played
because you need to move the Rook away
and now Knight comes in on C3 now you
have some ideas with Knight D5 also
Knight B5 Rook 88
and here you can play the move Rook ac1
bring the Rook into the game now you
have complete development even though
you're down a pawn but these Knights are
on the side of the board it's going to
take some time for blight for black to
try to equalize the equalize the game
and bring these pieces into the game
first so he can play the move Queen B8
Queen B8 and now you have Knight D5
activating the Knight and
when the Knight reaches on D5 most
likely you have to take because the
threat is Knight takes E7 rookie seven
some Bishop G5 idea so you normally take
this Knight Rook D5 and oftentimes we
see this Knight on H5
go back to G7 and bring it to E6 here a
little bit of pressure for white but
with accurate play block should be okay
here but let's go to the Geary game here
guys and see because this is a very very
big game here so let's see the last move
was King h8 and Anish is taking a lot of
time right here yes I was actually
analyzing Space six even before you guys
did because I knew you were gonna try to
grab this Pawn yes sir so 94 is the best
and easy to read come on be honest guys
come on and of course I knew that you
can try to grab the second part of
course so what's better than being one
ponna yeah so you got it but this book
unfortunately loses a very strong move
Queen B6 yeah six comes in and now you
realize that you're just overloaded here
because the Knight cannot move the
bishop is hanging and you really need to
play now C3 but C3 runs into this
problem Knight P3 attack in the rook and
also Knight C5 is coming in forking the
queen and the bishop so this is a very
very dangerous uh Pawn grabbing idea
yeah exactly so after King h8 Anish is
thinking he really doesn't have too many
options here either he has to bring the
rookie to D1 but I think it's more
natural to get this Knight developed so
you can bring this Rook into the game as
well here you'll have some options to
put the Knight on B3 maybe go to F3 as
well here so 92 is the best move here
and here black needs to decide what to
do you can play Bishop D2
Queen takes D2 and play the move A5 this
move is necessary now to protect the
before pawn and ideally what you want to
get here is the Rook on C8 and then play
the move 97 just to get rid of this
Knight on D5 white still a little bit
better here can play the move rook ac1
and then put the Rook on D1 here so
let's say h Rook C8 you can play but
Rook C8 now will be made by this move
Bishop A6 gaining a Tempo on The Rook
you don't have the move okay because of
Bishop B7 so you will have to play the
move Rook B8 and now we see the point of
this move Roxy one so you can play the
move C3
and try to open up the C file after
capturing and if it takes you have to
take back with the pawn here to make
sure this Knight cannot go to B4 or D4
and here you can switch back uh Rook B1
and Ninth is really badly placed on C6
and I see a very small advantage in this
position for white
so after King h8 this is I think what
Anish is trying to figure out Rook D1 or
92 everything else I think black doesn't
have any problems here while Knight D2
is a go-to move completing development
and we asked our viewers who do you
think will win the 2023 super bet chess
classic
they went with the guy in the lead yeah
we have a clear favorite Fabiano caruana
with 63 percent followed by eloisa
ferrusha despite his losses yesterday
and giria Robert about the same 12
percent Wesley not feeling the love I
mean not feeling the love at all and
wait a minute reports well how could
Fabi be in six if Richie wins
he will be the guy who's got a 63 chair
I mean you know come on I mean come on
come on you know that's that's just uh
too too too bizarre and by the way once
again our Twitter feed is open give us a
shout on uh any questions you might have
I do believe we do have Knight D2 on the
board uh of uh Anish Gary and uh again
VAR you just break it down statistically
how how does this Knight be won
variation there and is does it have a
name by the way who came up with Knight
B1
uh Knight B1 let's see don't call it the
Maryland Avenue variation because we got
a lot of grand Masters living on
Maryland Avenue here in the Central West
End it's a Sicilian Defense Lasker
Pelican variations svashnikov so it's
more of this uh come on pelic and that
goes back to the 1930s I mean yes uh
might be one is a latest wrinkle yeah 91
actually blocked us really well here I'm
not sure why Anish chose this viation
just based on the statistics it's black
is doing really well here really in this
in this how well is he doing uh after
Bishop E7 we have 57 for black and uh
so yeah it's and and if we go a couple
of more moves here in this position
current position sure yeah actually
sorry 28 for white 56 for a drawing 16.
it looks like for blackish
um
but all the games I see the top games
just draws couple of wins for black uh
yeah like you don't see like white
winning uh you know every other game or
anything here and the current position
92 is played 109 for Anish and 115 for
Yan I think Yan must be happy with the
opening outcome here he's got a you know
reasonable position and he's you know
he's comfortable playing this active
positions where he has some initiative I
think he's preparing this F5 move at
some point so we could see possibly Yan
even trying to maybe win this game
absolutely I was a little bit surprised
by move Bishop G5 takes D2 it's not like
the Knight on D2 was necessarily
terrifying I could imagine for example
even to move Bishop H6 and be pairing F5
but as we get prepared for our first
break it's usually a signal for us that
we've got to check in on our friends at
Q Boutique right across the street the
online store as well as the real store
to see what specials they have and guess
what they do have a special as a thank
you for watching the 2023 super bet
classic in Romania please enjoy 20 are
you kidding usually it's five percent
for friends and family so 20 is
ridiculous of all regular prize
merchandise today only but you have to
come up with a special code Romania or
ROM 20 at your checkout the offer is
only valid at cubatique St louis.com and
remember to use the promo code ROM 20 T
balanced day
well there you go thank you baby I'll
see you after the break
[Music]
we are here with Anna and Elisa Anna
Eliza welcome to the show tell us a bit
about how are you feeling to see all
these great players here the world
champion is here in Bucharest how do you
feel about that
it's my first time going to such a big
event and
we can't wait to see what happens next
when did you guys start playing chess
she's more integers than me yeah she
just kind of accompanies me oh I started
playing like one year ago
and what would you say was your favorite
player as you were picking up chess oh
that's hard to pick
I got into just because of the famous
you know YouTube the big Osmond welcome
chess
um it's hard to pick
um I'd say cargo picaro okay yeah yeah I
watch him on streams sometimes very cool
very cool and how about the Queen's
Gambit did you guys see that show
I wanted to see it I think I'm going to
save her sort like twice about three
times I'm not sure it was amazing I
loved it yeah yeah and from this
tournament who is your favorite player
who do you think is going to win this
tournament
I'm not sure we'll see what's um what
happens next honestly
yeah yeah
um I saw that he was like one Pawn up
and I was like oh this is us we're
getting a lot of Nepal fans here what is
it about Nepal what attracts you to his
playing style
or what to say about that
I don't think I can say anything about
the playing style but I think he's a
good player I mean right so that he was
against dingler and you know the world
championship and yeah
well guys thank you very much for
joining us Anna Eliza go enjoy the show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone to our live
coverage of the super bet chess classic
and here are the pairings for this
Championship Ram now see right today we
have ferocia playing mvl four and a half
points for farugia he needs a win Wesley
still playing Duda says story there Gary
against Napa once more a Rockford
against Carolina the last time I'm gonna
say
very nice and I tell you there are
certain positions in chess
that I really love because I feel that
they're strategic
I understand the ideas for both sides
you're you you're playing against a weak
Bond you're trying to get your Bishop
that's passive uh into the game from
behind the pawn structure you're trying
to cement your king because you have a
weakness and then there are positions I
hate
because there are no strategies it's
simply raw calculation I refer to the
game between Richie report and Fabi I
mean what are the Strategic out outlines
oh in these positions you always double
on the default what are you sure you're
good I mean it's all about calculation
and it's crazy this King on B2 King's on
opposite flanks usually a great
indication you're going to go out and
clobber one another's King but then
suddenly this is black Pawn on B3 which
is acting as a shield for white king and
this position I don't know about you
Nasi but I I think it's just completely
chaotic and random and it's also very
hard to evaluate the position because we
have so many questions
how many doubled pawns open King
undeveloped faces weaker Kings offside
Bishop no what's going on right and what
should I be doing should I be I mean I
think one thing is clear both players
are going for a checkmate
and uh is this the type of position that
will play into fabby's hands because we
know he's a great calculator but on the
other hand if I'm Richie and I need to
win I'm elated by this position jump in
bar and you try to break down is this a
position you would love you would say
gosh I I know exactly what I'm supposed
to do here as black and or white no I
think I'll be kind of uncomfortable in
both both situations it's not really my
style this position right it's very
sharp I was looking a little bit even
with the engine the sound of the moves
are very hard to understand because
white is not really trying to develop
from like Queen D4 is the main move in
this position and we have every game we
have in a database is just Queen D4
plate for White Queen D4 yes so let's be
my top move yes let's take a look
another thing I wanted to mention Fabi
has about 20 minutes already advantage
on the clock and that could play into a
crucial role at some point so uh maybe
not to any uh
20 minutes yeah
more like a 10 actually 10 minutes yes
so Saint Richard is taking a very rich
position here so let's take a look at
the the moves after the move Queen D4
here so Queen D4 played I see some uh
games in my database perhaps some
correspondence uh games here uh Queen D4
now uh main idea is to control this D6
break you always have to watch out for
the break here and uh black can play
Rook be8 is one option another move is a
logical move F6 to try to open up the f
file here in that case white can take
you can also play the move F3 but let's
look at the most forcing line take on F6
Queen takes F6 Queen F6 Rook F6 and we
play the move Bishop B3
and now we have this um you know
interesting end game here you have
pressure on D7 and this B3 Pawn is hard
to tell this is a strength or is a
weakness so because you know if we
exchange a lot of pieces most likely
this Pawn is gonna fall here so black
can play Rook F7 or Bishop C6 here
Bishop C6 looks natural defending the
pawn and opening up the B file
and again you have trouble here
developing uh developing this bishop
here so white can start out with the
move H4 he's not even in hurry to
develop this side of the board here H4
trying to get some space Rook E8
and
now we see the idea Rook H3 bring the
Rook on a third Rank and perhaps he
wants to play the move Rook G3 Bishop
not very natural moves here but this end
game is actually a little bit better uh
for white here
this particular position so after Bishop
B7 uh Richie is thinking and uh yeah
he's been thinking about almost 10
minutes now after this move Rook B8
another alternative here for him is to
play the move F3 try to shut down the
diagonal for this bishop and get the
bishop develop on the tree but in that
case again we have the move F6 is it
possible to try to get rid of this E5
Pawn or you can start with the move
Bishop C6 first this is a useful move to
protect these seven and also now your B3
Pawn is protected Bishop D3
E8
again this Pawn is a shield you don't
really want to take this Pawn right now
because then black can come back on a B
file and try to attack and the main idea
now for black is just this move F6 this
is what black wants to do to try to open
up the position otherwise H4 H5 Rook H3
and white
can have a very very strong attack here
so very sharp and a complicated position
guys
ah not I thank you Vara just like it's
exasperating for me because nothing uh
appears to be natural nothing looks
natural for me I you know I always look
at the attacking the aggressive moves
first so the idea is you look at checks
first because they're the most forcing
moves you look at captures and you look
at uh well aggressive threatening moves
so I'm looking at this position I see
the move Bishop B7 I also see this move
F7 F6 there's a little consternation
because there is an issue potentially
off the F2 Pawn so I'm thinking my
Bishop is a little stuck on F4 and I
want to stop the move F7 F6 so I'm
looking at the most you know like how I
can't make a check I can't make a
capture well let me aggress the queen
and maybe force the queen to a lesser
Square so you know the move I find to be
most natural is Bishop G5 and I don't
even think it's considered I don't even
know if any of the uh by Queen E6 yeah
but I see in my database they're all
these like uh really great names
[Music]
nepo and Lavon and the moment I played
Bishop G5 is the move I would play all
the database games including the force
correspondence games the guys who study
chess you know to the nth degree
nobody's played Bishop G5 so I just
assume it's a bad move if nobody's ever
played it and it's like the most natural
move at least for for me so nothing is
coming natural and the it's about prep
how well are they prepared us well Fabi
seems to be a little bit
moment yeah yeah but the positions
Edward was showing us after even the
queen exchange we get to the end game
and he just said why I think he said
white is better why yeah like how do you
evaluate that how did you meet yes look
at White's pawns how can white be better
in the end game but because B3 might be
a liability oh boy well that's a real
head scratcher for us let's just jump to
some of the other games that maybe we've
left it a little bit Wesley so versus uh
Duda Duda has shocked really shaken up
the tournament a table by winning his
soul game upsetting uh faruja yesterday
in a very nice game compliments to do
that and uh well he's got the black
pieces against Wesley so today
the situation
I don't know I mean uh are is this
something I should be concerned about or
is it something that should be
encouraging I'm not 100 sure yeah so
f2f4 let's get rid of the night ask the
Knight are you gonna sidestep or are you
going to capture if you capture I
imagine it's pretty even but maybe on a
good day I don't know the the the nice
symmetrical and yeah four versus four
three versus three probably just simply
even Steven uh farouja when we left it
we were Amazed by the sophistry of uh
the concept that Bishop F1 and Knight F3
to D2 and I'm not developing I'm
undeveloping can I put it like that
Bishop a7a6 okay so farusha has an idea
he's kind of going to chase this bishop
away to a lesser diagonal if you put it
here thank you very much uh I'll get a
Tempo and in the week meanwhile maybe my
Bishop will be better on on uh B2 then
the dark Square Bishop Bishop B5 and
inviting and balance thank you mentioned
that black in this position has that
idea to exchange Bishops and take C4
square away from whitesnite yes and at
the same time much like a I want to say
a slav
defense Exchange slav
es you'd simply lose the game because
you have the Double B pawns right so put
upon on D5 put upon on D4 and that's
your exchange law where you go Queen B3
and queen B6 and you lose because of the
double Pawn so inviting that imbalance
maybe that was something that farouja
would be very pleased with a very long
term term small advantage that white has
is it small though that was my question
so if I go for example Bishop to D2
maybe maybe I'm not 100 sure but I I I
probably would like to like let's say
you make a decent move I don't know if
this is a good move or a bad move
probably but this is like maybe my dream
come true that
I mean
um yeah B6 now the double pawns shows
that they're weak exactly yeah that's
exactly what I'm saying so uh definitely
MBL has got to avoid that so uh I I
don't know uh week
strong definitely not strong but it
might not be as weak as it seems yeah
Victor cortion always said to me and it
really uh struck a chord a weakness is
only a weakness if it can be attacked
VAR
um Ali Reza as he got reasons to be
pleased with the outcome of the opening
I'm still not sure I don't think so yeah
sir he he's really behind in development
and as we can see that Queen side Knight
is still on the original Square the
bishop and uh
he doesn't have that much he need if he
had a few more extra moves then maybe
but at the moment it's just a complete
complete equality uh I'll I can show a
couple of moves uh how the game can
progress there so 97 just played I I
like this move by um
mvl because you don't want to waste time
moving the bishop you just want to get
the pieces developed here and here the
question is what do you do you don't
really want to take on C5 because after
Knight takes C5 the Knight is gonna jump
in on B3 so he played the move Knight C3
but I think after this move now black
has a very natural move and also the
only move because otherwise you're just
gonna win the pawn so this is forcing
the matters because the move before is
out there right and now what do you do
now if you take I just exchange Rooks
Bishop before I feel like block only can
be better there because of the better
development so he's probably drinking to
play the move Knight B5
and and here black has a few options
here you can play the move Rook A4 this
is actually specifically against the
idea of A4 so white doesn't have this
move A4 and you can even double up the
Rooks very comfortable position for
black it's just equal and or you can
play another idea is B6
the point is now if you capture on C5 I
can just take back with the pawn and
then play the move Rook FB in in both
cases very easy position to play for
black king is already in the middle and
you have a better development here I
would be actually a little bit careful
for white here because of the
development and also I see some light
Square weaknesses here in this position
so before it's been played Knight B5 and
this is the moment B6 is a really good
move and Rook A4 and I think it's just
a completely equal position I don't see
getting any advantage uh in this game
it was precisely because of the move B5
B4
that I didn't want to play the move
Knight C3 had Ali Reza played the move
Bishop D2 in a sense preparing Knight
takes C5 as well as Knight C3 was there
anything in it for white in case of
Bishop D2 VAR yeah Bishop D2 is
definitely a move uh instead of 92 in
that case black can play the move Knight
E4 trying to jump in with the Knight and
put pressure on the bishop on D2 so I
take on C5 yeah if you take on C5 then
actually a very nice idea here if I just
take back with the Knight then I think
you will be happy that was my intention
absolutely you're maybe a little bit
better in this position but right there
is a very important in between move
Knight takes D2
and now if you capture back with the
Knight after Knight C5 Black is Black is
fine there and if you take on D7 right
Knight B3 comes in attacking The Rook at
the moment and remarkable Rook a two I
think takes D7 and then you're very very
awkward position you probably still
equalize with the move Knight D2 here uh
to get this Knight out because you have
this pin so you will probably just
equalize here but nothing more here but
the current position yeah I don't see uh
you know I see this game it's probably
just just gonna end the draw at some
point uh some danger here for alireza
you know just the engines already
slightly prefer Black's position because
of the better development here
absolutely the king actually ends up on
E7 maybe
playing an active role uh thank you for
that bar a nice uh uh nice insights
there going on again the game Marquee
matchup is just one of those games it's
just so it requires so much calculation
I'm referring to Richie Rapport versus
babies again and queen D4 is played by
the way guys Queen D4 played by Richie
the best move okay so now so again in
preparation by Richie and Fab maybe both
players showing their familiarity with
this because again that's a move I don't
think without preparation you would
independently find yourself because it
it's kind of makes no sense it doesn't
make that much sense yeah I mean Bishop
G5 and everything else and again uh to
remind people and this the championship
round where we stand right we have I'll
be leaving the tournament with half
Point ahead uh and quick closely
following firusha Wesley Anish and
Richard just half a point behind exactly
I had a one game just to keep an eye on
as so many games to keep an eye on but
Anish giri versus nepo uh while we were
on break you were telling me Nazi that
as a special cough player you're kind of
used to seeing the black queen going to
the king side that is to say you know
the bishop going to H6 the queen going
to H4 and black preparing the F7 F5
break Napa's decision to bring his Queen
to C5 a little bit off the Beaten Track
and we catch up with the players I think
we want to recapture with the beep bond
in this case even though we do split Our
Queen side we keep an eye over the D4
square and I think nepo is is not really
planning to play F5 and he wants to
start his counter play on The Queen side
maybe Rook B8 okay say this one yes and
let's say I'm Matthew
pardon me uh crickets here is uh yeah
well maybe Knight A5 can I sure it's a
little again it's a little bit weird
right because okay I'll I'll play these
stubborn pain in the butt uh type of
opposition here uh you know maybe
there's something
maybe I can use my so let's say I take
on B1 and then I go
after your
unprotected Pawn on A4 the yeah
it's working it's working new new
prospects great town Queen to A3 going
after simply asking me uh defend
yourself now it's weird that the first
you know I mean the move I want to play
of course is Rook B6 uh but it's weird
from the fact that my first rank is a
little bit weak so the desirable Rook B6
Queen takes A4 Bishop B3 I wouldn't mind
meeting the check with something like H2
and then I feel that Black's a little
wobbly the check however is really
annoying so maybe I have to take that
move Queen A4 a little bit more
seriously and
I don't know it looks a little bit
awkward to me this move Queen C2 I don't
know maybe a little bit better for white
it's it's tough because this backward
Pawn is a lot right now yeah but it's
like long term if nothing happens I'm
blockading upon blockading and then one
day a rook V6 might land so okay well
we'll keep an eye on this one Wesley so
as mentioned that seemed
and uh well I mean four versus four
three versus three we thought it was
pretty Even Stevens this tiniest
advantage to White maybe because Knight
seems to be a little bit better than the
bishop and then Ali Reza and by the way
that moved Rook a forward that wasn't
the most natural looking move to my eyes
uh I understand it but uh yeah I would
play Maybe Rook C8 or right I was
thinking the same thing myself Rook C8
this is bringing a rook to the open file
and then the total head scratcher and
you tell me what's going on because I
really I don't understand this situation
but apparently from a theoretician's
point of view this is the cat's meow
this is like great great great stuff and
the imbalances that are going on the
Kings on opposite flanks the strange
asset liability of uh the black Pond
shielding the White Queen the double
pawns on the seat file this offside
bishop and the the most
Queen D4 is is the best engine move yes
why it actually planning to take on D7
is that the idea of Queen D4
I think the idea really of Queen D4 is
that the construction of the queen on E3
and the bishop on F4 are is not that
great and we are constantly worried
about Rook coming to the e-file followed
by F6 and there's this you know there's
some hitting going on on F2 so if you
know like if you said to me well you can
have three moves in a row don't take
anything be three moves in a row to to
to move your pieces I might find myself
attracted to Queen D4 Bishop E3 F4 just
to take the sting out of F6 right and
even VAR was suggesting uh one one
possibility was the move F2 F3 to kill
that diagonal but again this bishop on
F4
isn't harming like arming Black's
position right it's not on on a diagonal
with a view
that was why I was trying to play Bishop
G5 it seems to me that the move Queen D4
is
to stop
the power if that's the right word to to
stop the potency of the move F7 F6 and
just to say to to to Black okay please
worry about your Pawn you know okay six
Bishop to D3 would seem to be right yeah
I'm definitely not afraid to sacrifice
please make my day yeah no Bishop takes
G2 yeah I mean it's sort of like okay
you know now I know what I'm doing I'm
playing you know Rook takes uh G7 check
and Bishop H6 and I got it I'm I'm right
back on track so yeah that that that's a
move but apparently Bishop D3 is not
hasn't been played before and I find
that move to be natural so uh VAR you
know you got to clear the cobwebs
because this is a really good morning St
Louis this is a tough one for us to
understand absolutely guys it's a very
top position to play I'm also trying to
understand uh the main idea here is for
black to play the move F6 without the
move F6 you don't really have a good
control play anywhere because the B file
is blocked you don't have a good way to
to attack again on C5 and D6 is never
going to work because the bishop is on
F4 doing a good job covering that so the
only option is to play for F6 and you
can play it immediately now after the
move Queen D4 or you can play Rook be8
and then play but One Way Or Not Another
you need the smooth F6 otherwise white
will just go Bishop D3 H4 H5 and to try
to give you a Checkmate right so you
need some type of Contra play here so
let's take a look now what Fabi can
really do here he can play F6
immediately which we analyze a little
bit or he can start with the move Rook B
E8 first to apply a little bit of
pressure here and here very likely we're
going to see this move H4
by Richie here the idea is to play H5 if
you're allowed to play H6 that'll be
great if H6 is played then this Pawn
could become a hook for later in the
game Rook H3 Rook G3 is another idea
that white wants to do in this position
so you can play F6 now immediately or
you can play the move Queen E6 first
it's it's very interesting to notice
that in in all these lines white never
takes the pawn on D7 because if you take
let's say on D7 you're allowing a
counter play and here in particular it's
a very nice tactic here Bishop takes G2
wow and if you take on E6 then we have F
takes E6 opening up the rook and this is
going to be a big problem Rook takes F4
comes in F2 is hanging black is doing
great here and if you take back
uh Bishop takes G2
and here we have the move Queen C4 and
now black is getting to that weak King
here F4 is hanging Queen C2 Queen A2 is
coming up here so Queen E6 actually
could be a very tricky move like a
setting up a little trap here just in
case if white takes the takes the bomb
but you don't really want to take that
pawn you just continue with your plan H5
now you want to play H6 and if black
plays the move H6 you play the move Rook
H3 and the question comes into mind here
what did really black achieve by waiting
all these moves before playing the move
F6 to go to that end game because
eventually at this point you're still
gonna need to play the move F6 here and
probably it's already necessary to do it
now before it gets too late after Rook
G3 because after Rook G3 you're not
going to have F6 Bishop H6 tactics so F6
will be played here and now it takes F6
and here if you play Queen F6 here
already this one is already a very
difficult end game for black because uh
White has made some progress in this
position and in particular there's a
very cool move here Rook E3 now you your
Rook was out of the game and now by
bringing on the three it's in the game
and D7 is hanging B3 I can start already
thinking about winning this Pawn here
and um
if rookie 3 Bishop takes C3 and white is
doing great here very very big Advantage
here if you try to attack with Rook ef8
I simply play the move G3 and again
there is no control play here and uh
this bishop 185 is out of uh out of uh
you know good squares to go to and
controlling some squares but other than
that not really doing anything you never
really want to play C6 because then you
will be blockading your other Bishop
like this is already a winning winning
end game for white so I think it's very
important for Fabi to decide to play
this move F6 I think the best is to play
it right now immediately to open up some
files for his Rooks thank you uh thank
you for that is uh definitely clarifies
a lot of what white strategy is all
about and by the way again we do invite
you our audience to send us your tweets
we enjoyed uh you're putting this to the
test yes you can send us your twizz
using hashtag super bad chess classic or
tagging crunches store and on YouTube
and tweet channels feel free to ask us
questions in the live chat
so I see now again it starts to be clear
that
I'm not developing I'm not playing the
traditional Bishop to D3 as white Bishop
to D3 Rook E1
why I can't the bishop on A5 which is
offside patrols the diagonal and
because so much of Black's counter play
relies upon F6 and of course if I take
on let me make a move H4 and if I allow
this counter play oops
this is the double attack that I fear
the most
I have to play bishop and queen takes F2
so so much of Black's counter play in
fact everything depends upon black
playing F7 F6 in a timely kind of
fashion so white gets out of the way
with the move Queen D4 so I finally
understand that exactly yeah it really
takes us a while right and if you delay
doing your F6
why it's not being sophisticated white
is just going h4h5
and you know we don't have to be Alpha
zero to appreciate the fact that upon on
H6 could really be uh you know as stuck
in our throat and that we do want to
play the move Rook E3 we can't play it
to E1 because as we said uh but and The
Rook up over
to G3 to E3 and because black is wasting
time with moves Bishop C6 Rook E8 not
getting on with business F6
why
it is improving a lot that's Bishop on
A5 as varges mentioned
has one uh possibility of really being
stuck out of the game and then it could
be you're playing a piece down suddenly
so if the advantage can grow very very
quickly and have it move on the boards
probably played Queen E6 okay
or no immediate
No rookie eight no immediate F6 no
Bishop C6 Queen E6 and that they're
still in theory with this move who has
played Queen E6 in the past bar big
names
uh I still see about four games played
in this position Yasser not not very big
names I think mostly correspondence I
think a very specific idea I see here
because I was trying to understand why
can't we just play H4 here and the point
here Fabi is trying to avoid the end
game so he's trying to play the move now
F6 and if there is a capture he take
back takes back with a rook
that's what he's trying to do here if he
couldn't do that with Queen on E7
because of Bishop G5 right so if if we
go to back that moment if you try to
recapture on The Rook just what you were
saying now see then we are inviting the
move Bishop G5 so okay so he sidesteps
um that and H4 he's still going to play
F6 right yes H4 is still a playable move
here for white another alternative is
you can just play the move Bishop D3
here as well Bishops so Bishop D3 Bishop
D3 just getting on with business
absolutely yeah you can play the move
Bishop D3 here in that case uh we're
gonna see I mean Bishop G2 could be
played but it's I I don't think obvious
could do that it's it's very very risky
here so I would get a platinum uh card
for the Palm grubbers uh Association for
contacting let's just look at it look at
it guys just got a phone card yeah uh
just for fun I know it looks like it's a
suicide here but it's really it's very
concrete Now The Rook is hanging so you
have to play Rook G1 okay and a very
important move here I think let's move
Bishop F3 hitting the right and then you
want to go maybe page five and
Bishop G6 to keep this fire block a
little bit of an advantage here for
white still but you do have to have to
move the Rook you don't have a way to
just just go for the then just give a
Checkmate here so look df1 or Rook C1 is
played and in that case you play the
move uh Bishop page five and hoping to
get the bishop
on G6 here again still still some
pressurized Europe G3 so again not
likely that this will happen so let's go
back here if black just plays more
normal
F6 for example here
trying to open up the position and in
this case after the move F6 we see this
move F3 it's recommended for two reasons
now the F2 Pawn is no longer going to be
hanging when the f file is open and
another one is you also cover your G2
Pawn right so now if you take white
actually can take with the bishop and I
like this because the Bishops are very
centralized and now you're ready to play
Rook H1 and suddenly you're playing a
different type of game where you have
everything in a center but they're
pointing towards the king and this would
be in actually an advantage for white
slightly better in this position so
after the move uh F3 here
you can play Rook B E8 okay to keep the
tension here and now we will enter it
takes F6
Queen takes F6 endgame is slightly
better for whiter and if you play a rook
takes F6
but you don't have this E1 score you
never have it that's the beauty of this
bishop you always cover this e13
otherwise you would want to play this
move and consolidate here and um here
again now Bishop comes back on F4 we see
some maybe repetition ideas uh King
takes B3 actually is a possibility here
because then you can hide the King on A2
but very complex position looks like
black has a compensation even if you
just lose the pawn there's enough pieces
on the board to create a counter play
you know it's funny in this exact
position that you're showing VAR uh to
my mind I mean long diagonals are like
magnets for the Bishops they love I'm
looking at your position bar and I'm
seeing the move Bishop C1 for white yes
I'm eyeballing the B3 upon but I really
like to play Bishop to B2 and give a
hakimate on the the G7 diagonal so
Bishop C1 I would find myself attracted
to the white position
yeah Bishop C1 then black actually wants
to maybe play them with Queen E5 and
trade through your plans and ruin my
plan and The Rook is active only five
because we're targeting the C5 pass so
this is a way but black can try to
equalize the game a very hard position
to play I agree this Bishops is just
very unusual you don't see too many
games played like this and you
definitely don't have experience in this
kind of imbalance positions absolutely
uh chaos for those of you joining as
light shame on you but earlier uh
Christian was interviewing the executive
director of the grand Chester Michael
korsakovski who did a reveal uh he
explained that Ding leren citing uh
tiredness I would like to be replaced
for the uh
uh Warsaw rapid and Blitz and this is
the roster of players simply wow I mean
come on come on
of course as soon as you say Magnus
Carlson it's you know it's going to be
an amazing event
next Sunday right I mean when you look
at uh voices
for good SEC
thank you it saved me uh they're the
10th see Poland's number one you know
like he's been in the 2700 Club really
really strong player and these are the
upcoming Grand Chester events right
we'll have super bad rapid and Blitz in
Poland starting this Sunday and then
another rapid and Blitz in Croatia in
July
and then we'll have tournaments coming
back to the United States St Louis rapid
and Bliss and sinkhold cup in November
and December lovely uh turning our
attention to the game of Anish giri for
a moment Anish could do himself a great
service in this game when we left it we
had just seen the movie take C3 and yes
we were warming up to anisha's situation
the backward Pawn on D6 and one for one
particular reason we were attracted to a
position where we could play we're
looking at it before just taking away
the square uh Knight C4 for a moment and
I thought Bingo Bongo I'm I'm dreaming
of such a nice control over the position
one way to get you to sign my score
sheet very quickly would be to drop back
with the Knight and allow Rook C4 I'm
liking this position for white because I
can really identify fi closely with my
next moves Rook to B1 seizing the open
file h2h3
making a loft for my king and black
snide on A5 is not making a great
impression quite easy play for white
here right I think that this is a
special macov player you mentioned
yourself not something that you want to
fall into I think that's why we're
looking at Rook B8 for black and
help me out here what was napo's point
of Knight A5 if you don't mind VAR I
mean I'm just finding that
to be a strange decision
I think he I think he simply misplayed
it yes sir because the current position
the move group before it's an excellent
move and white has a very very pleasant
Advantage there right I think he had to
fight for the B file here with a move
Rook a B8 and then uh you know we have
this queen A3 idea as well I think this
position is about equal here but the
current position I see some serious
chances for a niche so let's take a look
uh what can happen after the move Rook
B4 sure
so yeah Knight F5 96 is it's inaccurate
Knight is misplaced now on A5 and uh not
really be able to come back on C4
because if you play Knight C4 then you
run into this problem Knight B6 forking
your queen and the Rook here so he had
to play this move H6 again this doesn't
really help the 90s on the rim now play
a quiet move H6 and now Rook B4 uh is
the move that we are expecting here uh
the reason this is a really great move
next move you're gonna play Rook fb1 and
now you are controlling the B file
completely so if you play Rook ac8 try
to
you can't put this other Rook here
because you're gonna run into Knight B6
ideas
and now you're getting forked here so
that's why we have to play Rook ac8
and here you also have this move 97 that
is very interesting with the idea to
attack The Rook so another idea that you
need to look for because now after you
attack The Rook you're threatening
Bishop takes E6 and you have a knight G6
idea so and just just to point out it's
very important to know that if we get a
position like this this is a very very
big Advantage for white almost a winning
Advantage this combination the night
stack on A5 the bishop on D5 because you
cannot go back to C6 because always
going to run into the move Rook C4 and
after I double up the Rooks
in a lot of these lines you could
actually simply lose this knife so
something like this would be just
excellent for our initiation I'm seeing
some really good potential in this
position for Anish and especially the
other players who are tied with him
looks like Wesley game is just
absolutely confusing God same for Ali
alireza so with the win in this game
Anish has a good chance to force the
playoffs all right and that poll was
that deadly wrong we will see uh going
out with a flare actually I would be
very sympathetic to dingler in if that
was to be the case let's just pick up
the position between a diac Daniel dayak
and ding Loren when we left it we left
it around these parts uh there was Queen
C1 Queen C2 still theoretical position
Queen E2 just keeping an eye on the E5
pawn and the play went rather quickly to
at this position position take T5 I like
this move night I did this night on H5
does not make a power a very good
impression at least coming to F5 and EC
E6 squares black is kicking if you will
Rook D1 96 H4 Knight C6 and after the
move D6 apparently uh thank you darush
by the way uh on our production team uh
Lisa is there's a dingler in has played
all the accurate moves uh up to this
point his prep has been uh very very
good and
um
you know I mean saving his best for last
I mean I just don't even uh know how to
say it I mean Duda in the penultimate
round you know he's he got his first and
only win of the tournament so far
remember
is not the the worst Tournament of his
life and there you see uh the uh
expression of uh it looks very very and
he has two great options here guys he
has two good options first is to play
Bish Buffet very logical to exchange the
dark Square bishop and start trading uh
some pieces because he's upper full pawn
another option is just a little bit to
keep it more peace on the board is to
play Knight E7 here attacking The Rook
on D5 and then jump in with the Knight
F5 move I like that
he has a pretty decent Advantage this
could be
now the remarkable thing is after eight
rounds of play neither a diac who
actually has had a very good uh series
of appearances in a Bucharest he's won
some nice games neither Daniel nor
dingler in has won a single game between
them so in this tournament in this
tournament yes yes between themselves uh
yeah I I think Bishop f8 just as you
were saying very logical chasing but
there's something especially attractive
again maybe it's the French defense
player and me I've had so many wonderful
joyful experiences with a knight on F5
getting there with a gain of tempo is
very nice also when I look at this
position as black and I say I'm a pawn
up well one of the
compensations that White House is the
two Bishops this bishop patrolling this
long diagonal so I think to myself if
that long diagonal was empty air the G2
can have as much of the the long
diagonals as likes I'm not blundering
anything on the diagonal 97 Knight F5
has got my attention going back to our
Marquee matchup between Richie and Fabi
um a move we didn't really consider we
were looking morally more
uh the bishop coming to E3 in many cases
I think Bishop G3 has the same idea just
protecting the pawn on F2 so if Black
Goes F6 we can just exchange it and at
the end of the line corn on F2 is
completely safe so maybe we can take on
D7
spoken like a pawn grubber you know you
try to get honorary membership you're
gonna have to do a little bit better but
I like where you're going with this
queen takes D7 why not
why not I mean F2 is defended I'm not
blundering my Bishop on F4 is was the
case in other occasions and
seems like a pretty decent uh Pawn to me
still a little bit awkward Queen E4 here
guys Queen E4 for black queen E4 you
threatening maze you're encouraging here
I'm okay with that
okay I'm okay with Rook F2 that's
unpleasant
yeah because my king safety
uh is the problem right do you have to
drop back Queen D4
I mean you may have to give up your
queen for two Rooks but in that case
kind of like white because I see the
queen is coordinating with the Bishops
pretty nicely
um okay this is again it's it is nothing
strategic or anything like that it's
it's Stone Cold calculation uh VAR and
uh I like what uh Nazi is doing she's
capturing a pawn first of all she's
challenging the move Queen E4 and if you
capture the pawn on G2 aren't you
opening up the black king somewhat Queen
D4 and Rook G1
uh yes I think this can be played its
playable position after the line you
guys looking at it Queen D4 back
um black can play uh rookie eight there
after Queen D4 uh I have it on which one
preferable for White Queen H1 actually
it's it's losing because Rook takes H1
yes good Bishop takes H1 and then this
that's that that's why the queen is
really well placed here on D4 because
you have now this move Bishop E5 coming
in sweet attack in the rook and uh Rook
F7 yeah and now simply going for the
mate Queen H4 attacking on H7
if you play G6 it loses to the move
Bishop takes G6 right capture and queen
h8 mate so you have to do something
after Queen H4 and one idea is to play
on H6 and here uh the white position is
so good that even you can even take your
time of f4 to strengthen the position
and then you have ideas like Queen G3
Queen G6 and get into H7 really no
control play here the bishop is you know
not doing anything on A5 and there is
nothing really black can do it light
Bishops nothing incredibly powerful
actually yeah that looks pretty
one-sided to me
so uh in fact after the move Bishop G3
F6 is an option but the best move is
according to the engine is to play Move
F5 here
to give yourself some ideas maybe with
the F4 at some point but in this case
now white can play the move F4 and now
we get a completely different type of
position it's completely blocked
position here you have the E4 Square for
your Bishop so you can play for example
Bishop E4 here
and uh Bishop D3 you can do a pawn
sacrifice here with Bishop D3 and uh
perhaps white is a little bit better
here after Rook G1 at least your Center
is very secure here and you can have
some counter plays with the mubish page
4 and Bishop F6 so the choices between
uh F5 or F6 here in this position these
are the the two best moves here for
black that's just crazy I mean on the
one hand black is always playing for F6
and counter play that's what it's all
about the very next moment when I play
Bishop G3 shut it down play for F5 it's
like
make up your mind uh if you will as we
get prepared for a break we just remind
everybody of our current standings no
short draws today definitely not we have
a soul leader Fabiano caruana and a half
half a point behind four players fieruja
so giri and Robert trying to win and
catch Fabi at the moment Wesley and
borugia both of those games appear even
Steven so it's all about the Richie and
Anish game at the moment and
and just to remind everybody in case of
a tie there will be playoffs and those
playoffs will be coming up immediately
after the round ends and we're going to
see you on the other side of the spring
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
over the roughly one and a half
Millennium of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor of human Affairs an
event
[Music]
thank you
meet me
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our super bet
chess classic we are in the championship
round ninth and Final Round And here are
the parents right we have firuza playing
mvl Wesley playing Duda giri against the
Palm Niche Robert against Carolina on
all the sports white trying to score a
win and uh diac against it where black
is trying to score with at least it
appears that way to us amazing
developments in the game between Richie
and Fabi are marquee matchup as we don't
say this too often uh Fabi played his
first 10 moves more or less and maybe
yeah eight minutes or so but then the
next 10 moves eight moves yeah eight
moves pardon me an hour we spend the
whole hour so he's got 30 he's got 30
minutes left for the time control of 22
moves we don't say that very often and
when we left it the bishop G3 by Richie
was a a novelty a surprise but F7 F6 on
the board and this is a position where
you know all results are possible this
is
crazy
um just whoever calculates best kind of
situation also on our break we we really
like the game of Anish very very much
but right here during the break he kind
of well he did give away a massive
amount of his Advantage we really like
the move h2h3 bar and I were discussing
this during the break you just make Luft
and black can hardly move you can't move
the night because uh The Rook would
immediately come to C4 at Knight C6 Rook
C4 that's game over
at first this move Queen D3 looks very
seductive you just you just want to take
this pawn and your invite this
conceptually this is what you what black
really wants to avoid is a position
where the Knight is simply dominated by
the bishop the bishop controls all the
squares that Knight can go to even if
you play Queen takes A4 that was Black's
turn as well you wouldn't want this
Knight but there's a there's an Insight
that nepo found and that was not to take
the Knight he dropped back defended the
pawn on A6 now after the move h2h3 you
know I I mean Anish is still feeling
good about his position he's ready to
play Rook B1 but this is the moment
where nepo I think in some ways really
just saves the game he found this very
crucial move Knight B7 the night's
terrible on A5
switch it to C5 a dream position for the
ninth and it's yeah it's suddenly all
good the night uh attacks the queen
attacks the pawn it's doing things it's
attacking the pawn on A4 the night's
suddenly golden and thanks to the fact
that you don't have quickly Rook you if
your queen were on D2 you know there'd
be a problem on the B file but now the
Knight is actually getting to C5 with a
game of tempo uh first impression is
once I once we saw the move Knight B7
let's put that way we feel that uh
nepo's problems are behind him is that
the case for
yeah actually yesterday in fact you have
to be a little bit careful very quickly
you can get into some trouble here with
white with white knight on C5 is simply
fantastic this is a very strong play by
nepo very resourceful to put the queen
on A7 and now the best move to equalize
is just to play A5 here as white because
engines don't like it when the Knight
gets on C5 then A5 could be played and
you have a weaknesses on e4 A4 C3 so in
Anish as we can see on the clock he's
got 18 minutes and it's amazing few
moves ago we were you know thinking that
he has a great chance to win this game
and now he has to find uh you know the
accurate move to make sure he's not
worse I want to point out the key idea
in that H3 move that we were analyzing
during the break with you so there is
one very important idea here that it's
important to have the queen on D2 here
so let's say we were looking at the
movie H3 right and I was trying to
understand yeah sir what happens if he
still plays this move Queen A7 and try
to bring this Knight right back to C5
because you know ultimately that's what
you really want to do to have a knight
on C5 here and in this position you
actually can play a few different ways
here but this move apparently is
extremely strong Knight E3 now
you're attacking the pawn on D6 after
the exchange of the Bishops so and if
Bishop takes A2 in this position you
play Queen takes it and I was surprised
to see the such a big Advantage here for
white because again the Knight is really
misplaced here the weakness is on D6 and
now the weakness is also on F7 because
the king is on h8 and this is simply a
very very large Advantage here for white
in this position after the move Rook D1
and you can see it's very easy to play
for white you have Queen D5 ideas you
have the Knight jumping in on F5 you
have some Queen E2 Queen G4 really
quickly this is a plus two Advantage
here for a niche here so huge
opportunity missed by him here by
playing this move Queen D3 and you know
kudos to Jan for finding this queen A7
and now this move uh Knight B7 so here
if let's say you don't play this move A5
I want to show you why this can be a
problem here for white now Knight goes
to you you can actually start with A5 A5
maybe first attacking The Rook
Rook B5 and now we see this Knight
Landing to this fantastic Square on C5
now and you can never remove this knight
from here you don't have a dark soul
bishop or a pawn or anything to remove
this piece from here and you're always
going to be under pressure here on A4
and A4 you have to play Queen E3 here
and a very very interesting idea here
you can even play the movie K8 just
simply Defending Your Queen and
threatening to capture the weak Pawn on
A4 and now you have to play some awkward
moves like Bishop B3 here to try to
defend but it's very clear at this
moment that white is not playing for
Advantage any longer in fact he needs to
be careful
thank you for that far and let's jump to
the social media because we've got our
first tweet of the day let's see if our
audience can stump the Masters what do
we have I need help on my Russians
the question is in Robert Fabi game what
if Queen E3 B5 is met with Queen takes
A7 isn't this a double attack and the
Fabi Queen E3 B5
I'm not quite sure of the move Tempo uh
I think this was move 13. okay gotta go
we need three yeah D5 yeah yeah good
question why instead of playing C5 well
I could have taken on A7 so Queen E3 B5
Queen takes A7 that looks like a nasty
double attack uh Bishop is hanging Rook
is hanging and the question is can the
White Queen get trapped
yeah like in the worst case if I go
Bishop to B6 I take on B8
and can I trap oh I can take on f8 so
that's two that's a good point so that
didn't work it's a great move here guys
sorry for interrupting Bishop A6 here is
the bishop yeah yeah I was looking how
do I trap the queen so Bishop A6 Queen
takes A6 and then you play Queen C5
fantastic move here no way
wow okay I'm kind of speechless what is
yeah well the idea is C3 is hanging
right no okay
first and trapping the queen uh and if
you take on A5 I bought B takes C4 check
if you take now B takes C4 check and
pick it up the queen on A5
so this is the key idea nasty but can I
play Bishop E3 after Queen C5 uh let's
see after Queen C5 Play Bishop E3 yeah
then then we we have this move Queen
takes E5 attacking on C3
whoa this is really sophisticated you're
up a piece yeah my queen doesn't look
trapped yet no no he takes C4 yeah guys
if he takes C4 coming up very strong so
let's say I play Rook D4
yeah just uh first first of all I have
the move C5 is very strong another idea
is B takes C4 check uh but C5 playing
against an engine the C5 is very strong
C5 is very natural and strong just to
remove the Rook I again this is one of
those positions where strategically you
know all of the ideas of strategy go out
the window it's about cold calculation
and thank you to uh the questioner for a
moment because
these lines are deeper and far more
intense than I expected I thought Queen
takes A7 was just moving running into a
bishop B6 a perfunctory you know I'll
trap the queen type no no no no no Queen
takes A7 Bishop A6
and then the quiet move Queen C5 yeah
wow uh great question
and uh another tweet uh thank you for
the question I'm still not sure I know
the answer to the question but uh uh I'm
gonna run back and find out this one is
from Roll Tide one two three four a yes
sir and panel do you recall a time when
a member of the audience in the gallery
cause an interruption oh gosh yes
there's all kinds of uh when haven't
they yeah let's put it another way uh uh
very very uh nice question
um
I remember actually it was a world
championship in uh New York City in 1990
and I had the best gig ever I mean this
was great besselcock of a swift the CEO
of Swift it invited me
to do the commentary
in the Swift broadcast room and the
Swift room for the carp off versus
Kasparov world championship match was
this VIP room with you know uh
chandeliers and you know gilded's uh uh
walls and Great Buffet open bars I mean
and I and all the commentators were
upset with me because I had the Great
Escape
and uh they said okay yeah sir you have
to go into the audience room
and talk to the audience and then so
great I went there
and uh I like carpal's position and all
the grand Masters were coming to me and
making wages against me because they
like Gary's position and I was using the
BT Barnum line like a sucker's born
every minute you know and never give a
sucker an even break and 20 bucks is 20
bucks anyway I got killed all the
Grandmasters beat me the audience was
laughing the the the the the the
referees were saying silent silence
quiet quiet so I got kicked out of the
plane
I can't imagine that
it was terrible I had to go back to the
Swiss Suite
so I'm not sure about the audience uh
interrupting so much as the broadcasters
but yes we we have uh remind us of
sometimes uh where uh the audience I
loved playing in your old Yugoslavia
the audience was was such that if you
made a bad move they'd whistle they'd
call you on it like dude you made a bad
move
you know and the audience thought that
the board you know they would have these
Runners going and making so that in the
in in on the stage they make the move
and the uh and the runners go and tell
the move and they play it and they would
say you know the runner had the
messenger had made the wrong message
because the audience knew that wasn't a
good move so when the grand Masters made
a mistake
great they would call on it and how was
that allowed I don't know and I remember
the the great old man of Yugoslavian
chess fetusar gligrich uh
gligerich even at a very very Advanced
age was a very strong player
and he would come up with these
sacrificial ideas so you'd be sitting
there in the on stage
add
you know you'd be playing your game and
gligerich would be making a sacrifice
and the audience would be shouting
foreign
chess yes yes and some audience member
uh
we don't have stories like you just
absolutely not but a few times when we
have really young children watching and
they're well behaved they're told to be
quiet and they try to whisper something
to their parents but it doesn't come out
as it was for right and we can really
hear what they're saying and sometimes
it's really funny or cute and it makes
us laugh so
like it's an interruption but like the
two children today with the bow ties
right you know they're so cute and so
well unless you're in time trouble it's
it's not really a big disturbance yeah
uh something uh in the audience
something funny happened to you and
nothing like your story or nothing that
exciting but uh I play a lot of these
big open tournaments yeah sir World open
National open and you have this playing
call with two 300 players and you know
and also you have the spectators coming
in and you know it's very hard to
control to tell them hey you need to
turn off your cell phone so oftentimes
when I'm at this tournament spectacles
walk in and they're sunfall cell phone
is ringing and then you have the Arbiter
chasing after that person so it's always
funny to see that but we have some uh
development here guys and I wanted to
show you it looks like the world
champion has a chance now to win his
first game wow wow yeah ding is up a
pawn and I think it's uh it's very close
to the winning for him let me show you
how he got to the current position here
he actually played that move Knight E7
if you guys remember we were discussing
first or 97 97 is a stronger move it's
more concrete so he actually went for it
so 97 Rook D3
the reason you go to D3 is when Knight
F5 plate you can actually Retreat back
with the bishop if you put it on D2 then
your Bishop is simply stuck so Bishop
Knight F5 plate Bishop C1 by dayak it's
a it's a already a plus one here for
black but actually you got a little bit
better here because in this position
here they are had to play actively he
had to play the smooth Bishop G5 to try
to use his two Bishops here because
there are some weaknesses in the
position to try to create some counter
play for example if you play the move
Bishop E7 then there is a chance now
with this move Rook takes D4 this was
his best chance to try to try to escape
for a drop you can't take back with a
pawn your queen is hanging so you can
take on the four first Rook takes D4 and
you have to play Bishop G5 and here
actually you have significant drawing
chances because the opposite color of
the Bishops and you can try to put some
pressure on F7 so Rook D5 Bishop F6 and
you can play before or even if you play
B3 it's going to be extremely hard to
win this position for black because a
lot of the end games you'll have enough
activity against the F7 Pawn to try to
make a draw this is how he should have
played but instead of Bishop G5 he
played this move A4 positional idea
trying to prevent this move B5 but this
is this is too slow here and now dink
can simply play the move Queen C8
and to bring the queen to G4
we're also Queen to F5 here and uh he
has a much much bigger Advantage here if
you try to create Contra play play move
before then quick as well yeah the point
of B4 was also to try to get the bishop
on B2 here but it doesn't really work
that well takes on C5
btx C5 and you have to worry about uh
Knight E2 ideas at some point and uh
really really nice Advantage for for
dinkleren here another player who
suddenly has some chances guys is Wesley
so because he's in this end game now and
we see that Knight is better than a
bishop here because Bishop on C6 will be
just doing a defensive work against B5
not a big chance here but I see some
opportunities for him here after he will
trade Rooks I think this is the idea to
go for Rook C2 Rook A2 and then bring
the king to D4 so King E7 again not a
big chance but it's a pleasant position
to be in here because Rook A2 Knight A2
and King E6
King E3 if you go King D5 I will give
you a check and push you go back to E6
so King F5 H3 now getting ready to play
uh G4 and Knight will come on C3 the
problem is I have chances to maneuver my
knight but you always have to be there
on C6 defending this weakness this B5
Pawn is really really weak and
with a very accurate play most likely
you will hold this position but it's
very unpleasant because you just you
know you're only playing for a draw here
in Wesley can maneuver and try to put
some problems for black here not easy
but again he's he's the only one playing
for a win now sound is really does feel
like a two result game and by the way I
forgot my most remarkable story of
audience participation and disturbance
it helps oh gosh this is the best of a
mom it really helps if you're familiar
with the film Lawrence varabia from the
book Seven Pillars of wisdom about uh
well the the British Colonel uh who
helped the the Arabs unite against the
Turks and when the Turks would when the
arrows would attack the trains of the
Ottoman Empire they would go
this Victory cry okay so there I was in
Dubai in 1986 and I was leading the
United States team and the reports from
the newspapers in Dubai was Arab leads
United States team right and it was like
you know I I was something like plus
seven on board one as I think there's a
like really fantastic fantastic result
with each result it was like the the
headlines got bigger and bigger and
bigger until of course we played the
Soviet Union and their I was playing
Gary and they had these giant boards
where they had the very long poles to
hook the pieces and move them on the
squares sure enough we got into time
trouble bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang away we went and there was the guy
with the pole stopping looking he was
like 20 moves behind the players and
like and finally my flag that's a hard
job yeah right
finally my flag fell
and nobody knew what happened did you
ask her lose the game I was afraid I
lost the game on time and the Arbiter
gave me the score sheet said Phillip or
you're gonna catch up I was like
made the time control so there as they
caught up
with the position
it became very obvious that my g-pawn
was going to score a touchdown
coronation
and when the final position arrived on
the board and it was going to be
adjourned
it was like I'm not joking seriously it
was like 2 000 people in the playing
Hall all throngs of Arabic clothes
emiratis and they all started well
well they was in progress it was like
I gotta get out of here I must have not
been happy yeah and it was like two and
a half one and a half a US team won
against the mighty Soviet Squad and I
was the soul winner that was a very big
one
um I wanted to ask about the Richie
Rapport game because so much has
happened since we left it after the move
F7 F6 VAR please take it away because
Richie decided it was time to take the
pawn yes Richie went after like you say
pan grabbing yes he grabbed couple of
Pawns here but I think the Fabi is
playing very precisely and I think he
should be able to make a draw here so
let's take a look what happened now
after F6 Richie could have played the
move F3 which was another way to play
here just try to neutralize the Contra
play but he went for this concrete Queen
takes D7 and again this is the point of
the move Bishop G3 because now after the
exchange
uh if capture only five your Bishop is
no longer hanging you have time to
develop your pieces but uh it's a little
bit risky because you're not really
developing your pieces and here d-file
is open
the file is open now so let's take a
look Rook bd1 bd8 trying to exchange and
here he played the move uh Rook takes d8
and here White had an interesting idea
here to try to sacrifice The Exchange to
keep the file closed with the move Rook
D5 because if you capture with the
bishop then I play C takes D5 then it's
a very big Advantage for white now
because if you take on C4 I have the
move Bishop C4 in this case when Rook D5
is played Black has to take back with
the rook and then you take back with the
pawn and then you can recapture with the
bishop on D5 enter
even though white is up upon here
actually it's not even up upon here so
it looks like just the equality here and
the bishop is now well placed B3 is
defended and Richie probably you know
realize that you know there's not much
he can do here so it's just about equal
here so he played uh instead he just
took on the eight
Fabi recapture with the Rook
King takes B3 eliminating this Pawn but
again the problem is the development of
this pieces so now Rook D1 comes in very
important to pin the bishop so white
cannot develop F3 just played and this
is the current position here and Richie
is going to be up two pawns here
but if white cannot complete the
development he he simply cannot win this
game so for example Bishop C6 is an
interesting move here
and now he takes F6 GTX F6
so Rook to
g15 now black uh has few options not
even only one option he can do he can
start for example check
wow so you play King A2 right if you
play King A2 just Rook C1 just again
just specifically playing against the
moo Bishop of course and I think I I
don't see how white can play for a win
here I think it's going to be a
repetition here
King B2
Rook
Rook D1
let's go to the mvl game guys because I
think it's just gonna end in a draw very
shortly here symmetrical position four
and four four and four indeed and we're
seeing a repetition of checks with the
Rook although King G3 makes more sense
than kg1 in any case uh
for farugia a bit of well not a bit of a
disappointment let's be frank a massive
disappointing a loss in round eight that
uh Ali Reza is not bouncing back from
yes he had a good chance yesterday if he
didn't lose that game if he just drew
then today he'd be already looking at a
tiebreaker opportunity he would hope so
at least as our first result of the game
we haven't we didn't follow it too much
we just felt that out of the opening uh
Ali raisa's approach wow very
sophisticated pretty quickly it wasn't
really uh threatening well it depends
where you're applying mvl just handled
it really well and what happened if a
Fabby draws once more remind our viewers
say Fabi dros and feroza or giri drawers
then Fabi wins the tournament it's that
simple
and feroza did already drawn exactly and
our single result as far as we see the
French derby ended in a draw Anish Gary
versus nepo by the way kudos to uh Anish
because
it's not easy to find the move a4a5
from the previous yes from the previous
position where the Knight was kind of
stuck on A5 to suddenly put your Pawn on
A5 but the result but but the idea is to
avoid allowing Knight to C5 where it's
going to be a massively good night as
well as a685 then the Knight on C5 will
perpetually be attacking the pawn on A4
so a 4 A5 to equal to keep the game even
VAR as you explain absolutely and here
nepo is got two options he can continue
if he wants to continue play he's got a
big advantage on the clock perhaps try
to play for a win after the move Knight
C5 because with an iPhone C5 you're not
risking that much here Knight is really
well placed here or he can pretty much
force the draw by the move Knight takes
A5 I will show you the line now if you
take on A5 the white has to play the
move Rook A4 Force attacking the night
and now a knight goes back to B7
Rook takes A6 and now you have this move
Knight C5 ignoring the fact that your
queen is hanging but now you're
attacking the queen on D3 and now Rook
takes A7 Knight takes D3 and remember
earlier this Knight was on A5 doing
absolutely nothing out of place and now
D3 is very active and here it's just uh
completely equal position here we can
play Bishop C4 Knight goes back to C5
you can play F3 and uh you know more
exchanges are gonna come soon and yeah
weakness on D6 but so as the the panel
City so this is one way yeah can just
pretty much make a draw if he wants if
he wants to play for a win because he
has such a big lead on a clock 10
minutes for a niche with 14 moves to go
I see perhaps uh Nepal taking some
chances here with the move Knight C5
activating the Knight now attacking the
queen and putting some pressure on the
pawn on C2 of course there could be some
risk as well for him here because at
some point maybe rupee 6 could be played
as a really good Square for The Rook
there so Queen has to move
um you can play Queen E2 here
and now you're ready to double up your
Rooks and now a very important move he
has to find Rook B5
now you want to capture the pawn on A5
and if you take on B5 a takes B5 you're
going to be dropping this a pawn queen
takes B5
Rook A8 with the idea to capture the
pawn wow with Queen F5 so it actually
will lead to a forcing line that
probably ends in a drone Knight B6
Queen A5 Queen takes A5 Rook A5
Bishop E6 F takes E6 Knight C4 now
attacking the rook and the pawn on D6
you will play the move Rook H6 and F3
with idea Rook D1 so this should be a
draw as well here so very likely this
game is going to end in a draw and then
Wesley is the only person who can
possibly catch uh Fabiano if if that
game ends in indoor so there is a chance
that
so this game this game scan lead in a
draw so but let's take a look at
Fabiano's game that's the key game right
now I think they have repeated once
yeah
we can have a quick draw right now if
Richard goes Bishop E5 back
to G3 so Bishop uh okay so when we left
it we kind of left it around these parts
F3 Rook E1 Bishop takes E5 and what uh
what Richie is hoping is that Fabi will
be uh yeah and capture this Pawn on A3
but uh Bishop T3 let me interrupt myself
and uh pass the ball to Bucharest where
Christian is with Perugia
difficult game today I think he were
expecting maybe or hoping for a grufeld
from mvl was that way he started with
one before
um yeah
um yeah Maxine please go for it most of
the times but today he produced very
solid line
and yeah I couldn't remember so much
also and I think the game was very
balanced but the plan coming in today's
round was definitely to put as much
pressure as possible right yeah yeah but
he played brilliantly I think we have an
age here because my rookie is on E1 but
I couldn't find the
way to get Advantage so he played Bishop
B5 which is a very good move and I guess
there was nothing in the game
and I saw you towards there a bit
disappointed when you guys started
chopping everything off the board
um what are your initial feelings after
this tournament the conclusion of this
tournament yeah of course I'm very
disappointed with the yesterday game
it feels like the tournament was going
my way but yeah suddenly there was to do
the pretty brilliant game and it was a
very low quality game but from his side
it was okay and
yeah it was just the opening problem
yesterday I couldn't remember the line
and I was worse the whole game then I
got chances but
um it was it was not enough to make it
throws so in overall I'm very happy
after
um the loss with Wesley in the first
round yeah to get plus one to finish
with plus one is pretty good so
um last year a good minus one here so
it's a good start to the year I think
definitely an improvement and in fact
you played Maxim uh in last year's last
round as well that didn't go your way
but today uh um much easier Day at the
Office alireza congratulations for a
decent result for sure not after your
standards but still quite decent after a
difficult I'm satisfied with it yes
absolutely thank you very much alright
and we'll see you in the next uh
tournaments thank you very much uh thank
you for that Christian the one time I
want Ali Reza to play role of
commentator and uh I wanted to get his
uh a perspective of this uh actually fat
I find these endings fascinating uh a
knight versus Bishop because the rule of
thumb had always been when the our pawns
on both blanks of the board the bishop
is Superior in this particular case
because the pawn is stuck on B5
and F5 we kind of think well uh the
night is superior and it's a two result
game which I agree with I think that
white is definitely for choice but I
wanted to ask Ali Raisa as how close he
would evaluate it
in his absence and I see you have to do
the honors uh how do you feel is this uh
a game Wesley could win uh why it has
different definitely a more pleasant end
game but I don't see Wesley winning this
dude I would have to make some
very serious mistakes to allow white to
improve the position here right okay
well one one thing is is how do I get my
king into the game right so the move F7
F5 was designed to keep whites King at
Bay but we do see that white can
maneuver and try to create a zuk Swang
if we can you just think that black will
just wait for white skin keep just going
back and forth yeah right let's say King
F6 or King F6 right and now it's like I
need the D4 Square for both the king and
the night like if my night we're on D4
right now
the bishop would be forced to away and
then I could go King D5 as well
so I can give a check you will wait for
me I can maneuver my my knight but at
the moment I don't see also how do I
cross into uh Black's camp and if it's
not through the king side with G4
I don't know VAR uh
I thought it was a two result game but
now it looks closer and closer to our
driver oh one result game uh but you
have the game of uh nepo and Anish on
your board tell us about it yes uh just
just briefly uh let's look at that uh
this Rook B5 move is played and uh nepo
decided not to go for the Knight takes
A5 ID here which would have lead to this
lot of exchanges so he's actually
attempting to play for a win here after
the move Knight C5 Queen E2 played but
now he had to find a move Rook B5 very
important because otherwise Rook B6
could be played also Rook fb1 coming up
so he had to find the move rupee one and
now I think we're gonna see a lot of
exchanges happening and I think the game
is probably gonna fizzle out to a draw
Rook B5 takes Queen B5 will be played
and uh so earlier you mentioned Rook A8
but can black try taking on e4 instead
uh here yeah let's let's take a look
yeah
you can actually and maybe that's what
he wants to do try to keep the in
Balance here after this move uh there is
a risk of course because you left this
Pawn on A5 on the board and it's pretty
uh far Advanced so
there's there's two moves here C4 is one
of the best moves but it's a little bit
hard to play because it's just
blockading your Bishop here so the other
move I think is more logical Queen
before now attacking the Knight
and uh F5 let's say five
like a true special attack player you
maintain yes the uh Outpost sure and now
I think a white can
uh White has a few options one option is
Knight F4
not expensive yeah right me either a few
options Knight F4 was one so if you play
Bishop A2 then I have
A6 now yeah this is probably not gonna
happen this is hard to play holy smokes
and if I take I'm in trouble
if you take Rook A1
we need pinning
and uh check and checks all right yeah
if you play Queen C4 there's Queen B8
Queen A7 but uh yeah it looks like this
is still going to be okay for black you
just play the move Queen A7 Queen B2 and
we're gonna get and now I'll have to
play down an exchange yeah you have two
pawns so this should be uh oh I could
lose this it should be uh it should be
okay you and many others uh yes okay
seven yeah right yeah okay so yeah I
think black needs to play a four and
maybe try to put some pressure here but
this is one option uh for uh the game to
develop Queen B5 is uh it's not been
played yet uh an initial doesn't have as
much time and okay he just played Queen
B5 he has six and a half minutes with 11
moves to go in this position so let's
see so 94 is definitely the option to
play for a win
yes uh it's for a niche at the moment I
think he's probably going to be happy
with the draw with the time situation
but if yeah we know Jan can make a quick
move and let his opponent back in the
game here so that's something he
definitely needs to avoid in this game
making a quick move and uh missing
something he's got plenty of time and uh
he can take his time and try to find the
most precise moves in this position but
a lot depends on this game because it
looks like all the other games are
heading to a draw so if Anish manages to
somehow win this game then we'll have a
playoff that's what it all hinges up on
for sure because it does look like a
repetition is inevitable in the game
between Richard and Fabby Fabby doing
what he needs to do hold with black
maintain his half point lead see if his
uh closest Rivals the people pursuing
him can win uh thus far Ali Reza did not
manage to do that we don't think
Wesley's chances are
it's more visual than it is actual I
mean it just looks like white has a
better position and he does but very
hard to do something in the west they
say okay sorry yeah both of these games
that we see on the screen are racing to
a draw yeah and that means it all comes
down to anishi's position and remind me
of the uh times on the clocks right and
if it's down to six and a half minutes
against Nepal mission is 35. that's a
big difference on the clock time we have
11 moves to go six and a half minutes
for 11 moves a little bit awkward I feel
like maybe I should press to put an
Asian bigger time trouble because
position is not that simple the
Temptation is there the Temptation is
there but I can tell you you know when
you've been having
such an awkward tournament as Grandpa's
been having it sometimes it's a sort of
like you want to get it over with now
having said that we've just seen a move
by Napo that suggests that he's ready to
keep the game continuing well he gets
the pawn back on A5 and
I don't see any issues for black at all
in this position
of player I'm happy with this position I
think anybody especially in the car for
otherwise would be happy with the
position
22 was still passive yeah I was about to
say was it that a complacent or not
because you know it's
okay I I I I make a reveal I'm a pond
grubber you know like I don't know I was
attracted to you yeah exactly it's a
reveal you know Queen takes A5 and
what's not to like about Black's
position I mean
everything is super safe super solid and
uh well
this is of course Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen takes C3 right away uh upon
on F7 uh
and ifanish doesn't win this then Fab is
going to be the champion
yeah yeah the dinner's on Fabi a hundred
thousand dollars uh and uh an extra
Grand Chester point for a clear there's
teams 15 points 13 GCT points yes
exactly 1.2 million in total price
prizes for the grand chest tour very
nice in that extra hundred thousand
dollar bonus sorry can black boy just
Queen
looks very cozy doesn't it I mean
it used
yeah you know it's funny in these
positions
I I it's like my my instinct is to play
G6 and King G7 I just I can't really
articulate exactly why but it's always
like the king is just ever so slightly
safer but yeah I I like this idea of
Queen A3 and just played it and just uh
Invasion if you will you know you're
you're you're touching all the sore
spots in White's Camp E4 C3 and you Rook
on B2 uh for Anish
boy that it's amazing that one move and
it was the move Queen D3 and it looked
quite attractive to hit the pawn on A6
but it was like one move turned a very
nice Advantage into maybe slight
disadvantage he missed the Knight B7 I'd
say yeah pretty sure me too when nepo
revealed it was like oh dear why did I
the night on A5 was so weak put the
Knight on A5 and that was
feeling good fine Elena right he feels
confident now he has nothing to lose in
this position he has a big time
advantage
and worst case scenario for him gay
men's in a draw which he's happy with
exactly uh this is where nepa's strength
of you know putting the pressure on the
clock has paid off for him uh constantly
throughout his career I mean you don't
win two
candidate tournaments they're the
toughest tournaments in the world to win
uh without knowing how to put the
pressure on your opponent and through
the clock through his fast paced play
he's managed to do that by the way the
queen have three but I had mentioned G6
and King G7 Queen F3 is one way to stop
you know the potential of uh even doing
that because there's always a queen F6
check Queen F3 on the board and while
this game is still going on I quickly
want to jump to our world champions game
I think ding is very close to converting
his advantage
and he'll finish with a win well we
talked about the percentages as we had
shown the number of decisive games and
how 30 percent you know we were
expecting maybe Fabi to draw and then
somebody to win to catch Fabby but it's
ding you know they're like no no no okay
Queen
oh I did not like why it's king F4
that's lifting the kimono exposing the
white king a bit F2 F4 don't like this
move but maybe it was already the
position not necessarily the move at
this point as uh I mean if you if you
were trying to sidestep Bishop G3 don't
forget there is a 92 check so you can't
go King G1
and it's official Bobby made a draw so
he's got at least a tie for first yes in
the pocket yes and it's looking good
looking good it is indeed as we have two
results two draws Fabi entered the
competition with a half a point
Advantage only Wesley so and now
Michigan Gary can now tie him
correct and both of those positions
don't look so great for weight
and we think after the move F2 F4 I
break it down for us now see this move
F4 we don't like and exactly I like
things movable cage too
just right The Bishop's not under attack
right because the pawn is actually
pinned Rook H2 you like this no just
simply cringy uh yes so we have one more
move responded with Rook D2 and now just
cringey four Sims winning wow
wow probably every move is winning but I
can't do anything
I must say I find myself attracted it
looks very good with the idea of Rook H1
amongst other things it just looks like
White's King is just being overrun at
the moment Rook d3d2 on the board is
time Factor no it's just position right
yeah white position is absolutely
terrible
I must say for dioc this is not the
tournament that he will be remembered
for it's just uh he's been unsuccessful
with his result but his play also has
been
defensive how could I say it he's he's
been on the back foot he's had issues
with the time management and then in the
openings he's been getting slightly
worse positions
and I mean it's very tough yeah yeah
it looks a little bit uh frustrated for
Lauren because yeah this field is just
not given him any chances VAR jump in
how big an advantage does dingler in
have oh it's completely winning yes sir
it's like plus 80 and there are multiple
ways how he can win this game here
I can show you a few few of the options
here I really like this move for Queen
G4 suggested by nausea activating the
queen now attacking the G3 pawn and
if if you capture the bishop right if he
then I play this movie takes G2 and now
you cannot take back with this stroke D1
is hanging one so you have to take back
with the King and then simply Queen F3
check King goes to G1 and now we bring
this piece into the game okay shade and
now threatening Rook H1 made so same
story D1 is hanging so The Rook G2 Queen
takes D1 and it's gone C2 Queen D1 and
then yikes then give a Checkmate so that
that's one option there are many other
ways to play even even just like a quiet
Bishop F6 is very strong they're just no
moves here and then you can play Queen
G4 after that as well so but I think
Queen G4 is a pretty pretty simple move
for ding to play setting you're
basically setting up yourself for the
movable G2 so if Queen D3 comes in here
this is probably the best defense you're
defending G3 and also D1 now uh you can
continue with with Rook dh8 or you can
play the move Bishop F6 another winning
move here is also Knight F5 here
again you gotta calculate this move a
little bit but the point is now if you
take on d8
then there is the move
Bishop many ways to win 93 is winning
yeah I think just everything is winning
just black position a White's position
is just extremely weak here so I think
ding is just going to take his time and
find the winning idea a good way to
finish the tournament for the current
world champion getting that win this
will be I think important for his
confidence no question about it I mean
iOS is going to say spectacular win and
so unexpected because up to this moment
I mean ding was having a terrible
tournament no no no no no sugar coating
right we kept saying that Ding finish as
well and if you're here he will yeah he
will finish and he will he will be
pleased with himself because frankly he
played a really really good game I mean
did he make any errors did he make I
mean talk about accuracy right or
absolutely I mean the world champion
really saving his best for last yeah
absolutely this was a very precise play
by him it also helped because his
opponent played the risky line
sacrificing a pawn but looks like he
knew all the main ideas and this
maneuver 97 96 bring the Knight into the
game and of course they could have
played better in in uh in the middle
game but he did not and I think took
advantage of it he just won that pawn in
the opening and then just neutralized
that slowly and uh now he's got the
winning position
wow uh yeah again I didn't see this
coming because again uh dingler and had
been so unsuccessful to this point I
mean he certainly didn't have the body
language coming into today's contest uh
as you know like I'm gonna win this game
yeah with the black pieces it was more
like oh please dear Lord let me out of
this uh uh Horror by then this just
shows that even when someone like him
world champion uh he's having a
repeating Wesley play for a win
absolutely a wounded world champion is
still a world champion and I see that in
the game between Wesley and uh dude uh
Wesley is basically giving up yeah
trying on his attempts yes a draw uh
so 5p only has to watch out for
unleashes possible win otherwise he will
be in the clear first yeah some crazy
contrast here between ding lyrin for
just a moment because really had a bad
tournament and Wesley so so Wesley
starts with this huge win uh beats the
reigning Grand Chester Champion the
number one seed in the tournament
everything's set up for himself draws
eight in a row thank you for
participating like what and with those
eight draws had many many chances of
possibly scoring more at least in two
games at least yeah so a very very
strange contrast of Fortunes between
these two players Wesley so and Diggler
in and let's keep a
watchful eye Because by the way ding
Lauren played what I thought was the
most compelling move for me was rook h8
and after Queen D5 F6 Queen takes
players are playing quick very quickly
Knight takes dingler in is about to play
Knight E3 check which has to be
prevented as well as as uh pardon me
right you can't play Bishop D4 here now
absolutely Knight takes G3 check if
Knight takes G3 check as well as Knight
E3 check on tap so thanks to this uh to
defend both threats and I like your move
Bishop dt4 just
you know setting up you know and just
saying for a while it's out of moves
yeah really this bishop cannot move Rook
F2 check
he played C s might be even better yes I
think it's better than
C4 Bishop D4 because
running across one now I think age one
so Bishop takes H1 Rook takes back
Knight D4 check you want to play that's
my idea okay and I gotta go King
no you do that what else do you have to
check this is the kill yeah that's the
kill
if you go to E3 I'm not going to Fork
you I'm going to check media oh no say
it's not so rookie too
ouch
and if I go to this looks Dreadful
but uh let's jump to Bucharest as a
Christian with our tournament leader
thanks yes Fabi first of all welcome
back to Studio congratulations on a
successful tournament uh in today's game
what started at an aggressive opening
from Richie fizzled out into more or
less a piece of result quite quickly
tell us about your initial feelings
after this game yeah it's I mean it's a
good result you know I had black there's
a lot of people trailing me but if I
drew then I at least I couldn't be
overtaken and maybe a playoff but I was
also feeling like uh Maxine is starting
to play quite decently in the tournament
I mean he has a bad game against me but
he's he's playing quite decently so I
didn't think that he would uh that he
would lose today that was my feeling at
least and you were right about that yeah
that was very good and Jan I wasn't sure
of course because obviously he's not in
a mood where he's like
he's definitely not in a great mood in
this tournament but it looks like he
played a nice game uh were you worried
when he started with C5
when he played when he played C5 I was
sure he would play the Four Knights the
four nights and it's a really good
opening
it's also like a drawing opening I mean
it's a like yeah you can play the petrol
but like like he plays of course but
it's it's no worse in terms of if you
want to like play a very solid game yeah
and okay so I I mean Richie played a
really
well I aligned a ding played so I was
hesitating
um because there's Bishop B4 here
and and Jan played Bishop C5 in the
match yeah which we know is not the most
optimal move probably no it's it's a
good move it equalizes I think like it's
the top line if you leave like really
powerful engine running for a while it
says it's basically four straw yeah but
I was just curious what they had
prepared against Bishop wave five so I
decided to play it
um I was like hesitating a bit here
because both moves I know are quite
decent but this one is much sharper
actually this was like first play
against Me by Magnus yeah in 2019 yeah
and I didn't know what to do then but I
I found the right way
and I think he he played Bishop D3 here
I mean this was the game something like
this
I think Queen E3
and I forgot Bishop C6 I think I played
I don't know I played I think I played
work at Via work f8 and it's a four
stroke
um as well
Queen E3 is much more dangerous and this
was played I think a lot of games like
John plays it
um Hans played it
against in the same field Hub yeah yes I
mean yeah a shocker played D6 move which
has no like
you know you need to create counter play
because you can't play D6 in this
position you're going to get attacked so
you need to go
um and I kind of knew I was also
spending some time up to this point like
it didn't feel like he prepared anything
Ultra sharp Ultra new oh were you having
the same feeling or maybe he thought I
would play Bishop B4 instead of this
maybe he didn't think I would go for
Bishop C5 because I think I played
Bishop before mostly in the past but
like we both knew this line I'm sure
it's just that I couldn't like remember
uh a lot of details I mean I remember
that this is losing because of this but
this I I figured out over the board
against Magnus four years ago so it
wasn't difficult to remember
and C5 this was played I think a lot and
I think a lot of them played F6 against
John
yeah and it's not very accurate because
of this
uh
so
like I was trying to remember this
position I was trying to figure it out
uh I thought I was very happy when I
found this move because the point is of
Queen D7 actually I have this very nice
shot Bishop G2
and then it's some geometry I take here
and then I have Queen C2 and queen F4
um and even if it takes only six you're
a queen and that opens up yeah and this
at least I wasn't sure if it's like
winning or not but okay it's obviously
that would work not White Once yeah so
he went here I thought this was critical
I was
I was like
um
trying to figure this position out and I
think this is what the engine was
recommending as well yeah I was gonna
play F6 trying to go quick for the the
point is he he kind of wants an end game
uh but he doesn't really get it in time
like and the queen E6 is important
because if I play F6 first
then he has this bishop G5
and I I can sack The Exchange I think
but I didn't believe it I didn't believe
that this was working out yeah
um
and if I take with the queen
then yeah now the point is that his
Bishop was to E3 it's actually better
square and it covers the e-file and I
thought it would be worse here so you
were more or less on your own at this
point you're out of Europe I mean like I
knew the main idea so I was figuring it
out by by knowing the main ideas in the
position
and Bishop G3 okay looked possible but I
didn't
and here I hear I was very worried about
F3
it's a very interesting move because
let's say if we get this version of the
end game I think this is not very good
I think this is the worst version
and the problem is if I go to Queen G6 I
threaten like Queen Z2 but there's
Bishop D3
and queen H6 or like Queen F7 for
example there's C6 and this actually
wins a piece yeah only five game over
and so I I was like looking at this
position Queen A6 so there's no C6 and I
have like
well I always look at Rook D7 this I
thought that I get like Rook D7 any
Trends made and then and now the point
is that C6 I I take his Rook so I
provoked it and uh and like rookie 8 is
coming I mean
it's a very short position
so I was thinking that this works out
but I'm sorry and I think it does I was
I was still worried about this F3
um
like but yeah he he didn't go for it so
I was kind of happy because I thought
that this end game
um I thought there was just one subtlety
because if I play Work FDA then Rook D5
and I was worried about this because I
like if I take with the bishop then his
pawns become very powerful and you
cannot take it back because yeah and if
I take with the Rook then he takes on F6
and I don't like I need my Rook on f8 to
capture back
um so and I thought like he also
threatened C6 somewhere maybe so I was
worried about this one and that's why I
played Rook here and now if here I just
take with the Rook and take Rook takes
and yeah I wasn't worried about this
position I thought it's just a draw lots
of details seems to have been calculated
quite correctly yeah and here I was like
maybe were you still worried at this
point or we're not actually playing for
it I thought like every every move is a
draw I wasn't really playing for a win
and maybe I should have done this maybe
it was like
a little bit dangerous this one
but yeah his King can run to A4 which is
but maybe I should have gone for it
and he actually he has an only path I
didn't realize I was so
can be fun
yeah I actually didn't realize this I
probably should have spent a bit more
time I might have
I might have tried this one but I would
have also be worried because here his
King goes to A6 I guess all the way
and his King could start to capture some
problems okay I thought this was just a
drawing I mean why not take it at this
point the strategy has been clear from
the beginning I mean I would have been
so tempted if I saw this before
but only Richie mentioned it after the
game that he was worried about it but
then I wonder like he oh yeah he
actually said F3 Bishop C6 that's that's
what he mentioned
and if I get Bishop A4 then my Pawn is
super strong so the point being that he
cannot take because you just give a
check and now you have Bish pay for is
that well if he goes to A2 Bishop C3 I
think
and if he goes to situ then which
probably his King starts to get hunted
yeah although I I don't know if it's
like really bad or fight or not but
um
yeah I think that he should have
like he should have tried F3 here I
think it's a much better try yeah
probably he was like kind of familiar
with this position but not
um maybe he couldn't remember the
details
well a decent result for you plus two it
does seem like uh for the most part at
least up to this point the results are
working in your favor the last player
that could potentially catch you is
Anish with the white pieces but his
position is not looking very promising
to play for a victory
um how are you feeling right now what's
the aftermath of this tournament what
are you planning on doing later on
tonight oh yeah this is a this is a good
outcome of course this game I mean black
is a bit better
but
I don't know like he could get ambitious
but the thing is even if you're
ambitious like you can also play for an
event in a safe way but I would prefer
that young just you know like plays it
makes a troll don't try to win this no
no but I think Young played a good game
I was actually very interested in this
king h8 move
because I am just to uh stop you for a
second it does feel like the world
champion tingly ran did get
a crucial last round Victory with the
black pieces against Bolton Daniel they
are good finish for ding liran to watch
some of his previous scenes in this talk
yeah I was like interested in this
moment because okay Anish played in a
rare lamp it's an interesting one it's
like computers kind of like it for white
yeah
um
and you've studied this a little bit I
remembered that like A5 and white tries
to play C3 and this King was interesting
because
it's inviting Bishop Basics but then it
probably F5 comes
I would say Bishop B7 fe4 because I was
looking at this queen E4 and id4 and
Bishop five hmm
um but yeah maybe Queen D1 but it's
super difficult for white to go for this
yeah so he played Knight T2
I I like how how young approached
although the computer
yeah C3 was maybe maybe a wrong choice
it felt a little bit like it's
simplifying Black's life yeah well Fabi
thank you for joining us uh
congratulations and we'll see you soon
at the closing ceremony
thank you Christian and our
congratulations also uh to Fabi as he
secures at least a type of first
probably clear first as our results so
far yeah right congrats Fabi and we have
three draws today between the French
players ferozan and VL Wesley and Duda
and Bradford and Carolina and also
congratulations to ding I mean it's
really really tough even if you are
world champion uh but uh he will be a
very very appreciative that he got a
chance he got his victory uh his only
victory in the tournament and it was a
good one yeah I've got some writing
points back too yeah
it's sort of like it's a Bittersweet but
yes it really really does matter that
you could be having the worst Tournament
of your life but in the in the
championship rounds you win rounds
you know eight and nine you know you
feel so much better about your result
winning round nine uh our congression
you know all's well that ends well so
yeah there you go and uh and look at
that line score not a line score that
the world champion is going to be proud
of but like you said a good finish
uh Queen B2 and I as I was hearing
fobby's uh explanation about the current
position in the Anish Gary game Bobby's
basically saying blacks slightly better
VAR is that an opinion that the engine
agrees with
um very very slightly I think it's just
almost equal and anisha's played the
correct move Rook D1 the problem is C3
Pawn is weak yes but also the D6 Pawn is
weak and you don't have a clear way to
activate uh you know your pieces here
there's always some Contra play in this
position and oftentimes we see an idea
where Knight comes to E3 now exchanging
the Bishops and then you have the D6
Pawn hanging so I like this move Rook D1
the main problem is unicious clock here
he has about two and a half minutes left
and we are on move 34 so he still has
six more moves to play here so after the
move uh Rook D1 now let's see if black
tries to do anything concrete here I
mean you can play Rook d8 but really
you're not really attempting to win this
game with the move Rook d8 here another
option is to try to play Rook A8 to play
Rook A1 to trade the Rooks but in this
case I was analyzing uh this position
there is a move actually not Knight C7
now
and now you have the The Rook is hanging
and Bishop C4
Knight takes A8
and here you can play the move Queen B8
it looks like the Knight is trapped
but I can defend it but you have Rook A1
yeah defending it
and you don't have a good way to get
this Knight back into game but I don't
have another way to put more pressure on
it so I can play Knight B3 but again
this is something that maybe would be
what Jan should try to do while Anish
only has two minutes on the clock
because there are some only moves you
have to find in this position like you
have to find a move Rook A3 which is the
only move here whoa sorry uh VAR uh the
move Knight C5 to a
six
uh Knight c5286 here no after Rook A1
yeah I'm just trying to start or Bishop
to ah Bishop A6 F7 is hanging I'm trying
to take the Knight yes yes I understand
there is there is a rook A4 idea here
that is the pressure and if you move the
bishop there's Queen F5 and you need
this bishop on C4 because you always
need to protect them F7 Pawn so this
actually leads to a repetition yes sir
with 2K5 Bishop C4 gotcha so this is one
idea that could happen uh what else Yani
really can do here because you really
want to make things complicated while
your opponent has only two minutes but
the way our niche's pieces are set up
they're all protecting each other is a
very good consolidation here between
white piece very hard to create any
chances here for
yeah well but once again that line with
Rook a a knight C7 isn't intuitively
obvious right Knight C7 Bishop takes C4
Knight takes A8 now I'll just uh you
know with two minutes on the clock I
wasn't going right you start to get
worried Bishop takes C4 Knight takes A8
I will just point out
uh that if I have G6 King G7 Bishop E2
is a super super sweet uh it and uh in
this position this is I mean I I
wouldn't trust my my calculation with
two minutes right right but I'm pretty
sure why I didn't have to play Knights
yeah there is another move here guys in
this position after the move Rook A8
because the reason I'm trying rookie
because at least I'm trying to play the
rookie one according to do something
before the time control ends complicated
so Rook A8 actually if you don't want to
play the move 97 you can you have
another very safe option which is Knight
E3
that's safe it's very likely that Anish
will do this because now you're
attacking the pawn on D6 and if I go
Rook A1 Rook A1 I mean I'm not afraid of
you trading on each takes E6 I'll take
with the pawn yeah you have to take back
with the pawn and here is a key move
here Knight C4 attacking the queen and
the pawn on D6 and now you still have
your queen defending the D1 Rook so that
forces the
Queen takes D1 Queen takes C3 and Knight
D6
just in time just in time to
force the equality it's still here maybe
he can try maybe a few more moves you
know a few more moves perhaps you can
try but white has enough control play
with 98 and some Queen G4 ideas as well
coming up
wow wow wow wow uh all this with only
two minutes on the clock Nazi yes and it
has two and a half minutes and nepo has
14 minutes and he's played the most
complex and he played okay I want to see
if Anish goes for 97. maybe while Jan
was thinking he did calculate everything
with Knight C7
I would I tip my hat to my opponent and
say good luck with that I would think 93
93 is very likely yeah to to stay chill
again and can't think too long that
ticking clock two minutes
sorry it keeps kind of standing let's
just play Queen E3 Maybe
well that that was what the problem is
is I saw Rook A1 and it's sort of like
the E Pawn becomes tender doesn't it
so let's say I take and go King H2 take
single King H2 and can I tickle this I
was looking at Queen A4 I guess Knight
B6 is still okay
Queen A4 I think the one thing you want
to avoid is an ending like this you
don't want to get caught maybe in a
queen and Knight versus queen and Bishop
where maybe you end up with pawns on D5
and C4 yeah passive Bishop but
um
objectively it should still be fine for
white
and defendable for sure
yeah I think that's fair
and remember Anish needs to win to force
any kind of playoff and for Fabi he's
he's saying nepo I'm not your biggest
fan but uh you can do me a solid by
making a draw and let's go to a view
from Bucharest
thanks to us yes yes we are we're
addingly ran our world champion here in
Bucharest ding welcome back to the
studio congratulations on finishing this
tournament with an important victory
yeah thank you tell us a bit about
today's game did you expect Bogdan to
come out swinging like he did Sweeney
like with a sharp sword aggressive
Robert told me that he sometimes will
press the clock very hard okay but today
he no it doesn't it didn't happen and
but he came out very aggressive yeah
reversing with his opening
and he played this D5 Pawn sacrifice
very popular
maybe 10 years ago yeah
yeah
it will also move Annie's played against
the uh Magnus in huacanzi
and here let's play D6 here 27 and
he got himself in some trouble in that
game he actually lost that game yes but
you had some improvements I remember
it's a old line Old Main Line yeah but
G6 is
and no way yeah
also there are many games with this guy
here I try to remember my preparations
before
yeah Queen C7 I think it's a move
if rookie 8 seems to be the bad the
second most played move in the position
yeah if Knight C3 97 it also possible
Bishop H6
c796397 here you might have Knight D5 or
maybe file yes take tank
now it seems like he has very strong
initiative yeah for uh for the pawn
but he didn't do that
after Queen to C7
[Music]
he played the move Bishop to H6
yes I do
is if nice things right here can take on
E5 my release don't f8 and it protects
the Palm episode seven there's no Queen
takes F7 very nice yeah so he wanted
that but with Bishop to H6 first right
so he had to play Bishop H6 first and
now I can go Knight F5 yeah this has
more details that's a nice intermediary
remove very cool and we were kind of
discussing this position we didn't know
where to put the queen going to G4
but I have F5 I guess
yeah F5 was one of the moves Rook d8 is
also a great box 93 D5 I also consider
taking a look
yeah
and that's probably the most precise
if it takes it takes
with a queen with a bishop
yeah you played a really precise game in
in this one and uh when did you feel at
what point did you feel like you're
taking over the initiative you're
gaining the advantage in this game
actually I didn't like Rook D1 I thought
he would take on G7 play Rook D1 here I
have to go D6 yeah yeah
takes I take a bishop Queen to D3 or D2
Bishop E7
Rook D7 yes
a queen C6 oh the Moon I mean
that's better
but this is such a difficult move to
make yeah putting the queen on the same
diagonal as the bishop Maybe 95.
yeah this is not easy though
Queen E6
especially from afar it looks scary yeah
it looks great scary also
I will consider and take
take and Bishop and fixed Maybe
black also better by rookie too
and because he Bishop Bishop can put on
D5 then he's better but yeah not so
you're putting the bishop first on D4 if
he moves the Knight very nice and he
didn't go for this he went for for okay
D1
and now he started you know pushing the
H Pawn trying to open up the position
trying to get to your king but you had a
lot of pieces next to your king there's
a lot of knights
actually belongs to H6 yeah and but
somehow here there's
if if he goes interesting yeah I have
the dark Square bishop and he didn't
come control my dark Square over my king
size yeah yeah so it's there's no way
you would love to play Queen F6 the
problem is you cannot fly the Knight and
Bishop then it will be very strong but
are not so many pieces here yeah
so I'm not worried and at this point
after Queen to D7 I think this was a
very precise move by you as well he
started you know
showing that he's not feeling
comfortable with the position he was
like shaking his head he he felt like
he's in deep trouble at this point yeah
and um
quite interesting I remember I forgot if
you take her which move here
he drops the punk oh he he dropped the
pawn at some point oh yes it takes but
he
maybe two hearts
fell yes yeah yeah very very unfortunate
difficult position anyway at this point
and I think he converted with great
Precision ding congratulations uh for
the last round sure the event didn't go
your way what is next for you right now
let's have to go back to
to rest some for some time get some rest
do you know what your next tournament is
or you don't have that mapped out yet
for now it's a global chess League yeah
in Dubai in Dubai yes yes well we'll see
you there for sure so thanks for joining
us thanks for playing here in Bucharest
I hope you enjoyed it and uh we'll see
you soon thank you thank you guys thank
you Chris and our congratulations to the
world champion uh for winning and again
it's not been his uh his event but uh
certainly winning the last round uh is
sweet
um the remaining game Manish giri needs
to win
is he going too far
uh I don't think so he does he just made
time control and uh he's holding a draw
with some precise moves here and he just
played his 48th move 98 which is the
correct move because he needs to create
some Contra play against the G7 pawn and
uh I think there are a few different
ways how this game will feels a lot to
draw let's see here what should a young
play so after the move 98 he can play
the move Queen D4 which is very logical
putting pressure on F2 as well as E4 and
E4 yeah so you play the move Queen F3
now because you want to combine the
defense of this pawns and also at the
same time now you're activating your
queen threatening the move Queen F7
right so here's uh Knight F4 is a very
logical move because you want to try to
blockade that uh you know Queen from
coming to F7
I have a question yes instead of Knight
F4 can I just play Queen D7
uh trapping your knight and then I want
to just move my knight and
uh Queen uh D7 is a possibility but I
can also try to pin you back with the
smooth Queen D1 oh and now I'm trying to
escape with Knight C7 got it I thought
you're gonna have to go Queen f8 and
then I was about to say maybe this is a
queen f8 it's uh Knight F4 comes in it's
two
so that's why
um here uh I was analyzing the move
Knight F4 okay but you play the move H4
you play G3 and it looks it looks really
bad Queen D7 and the Knight is trapped
right but then you have this move G3
comes in now attacking the Knight
and uh you you have to play the move
Knight G6 which is the best option you
end up up a pawn actually after H5 here
but uh the fact that your pawns are
doubled you have absolutely no chances
to win this end game because you don't
have any Palm breaks or anything and the
spawns are just really really weak so
maybe something like this can happen and
young can try to play for a little bit
but Anish should be able to hold this
position thank you VAR great relief to
make the time control because we saw
that the last 10 moves or so uh Anish
was the one with very little time on
this clock as nepo went into this most
forcing of lines and 98
on Niche is so accurate even in those
moments when he seems to be on the back
foot but as a reminder of the grand
chest tour events let's go through the
list once more as this tournament in
Bucharest wine Style
the event will be
Superbad rapid and Blitz in Poland that
starts this Sunday featuring a world
number one player Magnus Carlson joining
the tour and after that there will be
another rapid emblades in Croatia in
July will also be playing exactly and
later this year in November and December
the players will come to St Louis for
rapid and Blitz and single cup we're at
the Grand Chester 2023 will be a crown
and just to remind in less than a week I
think it's Sunday to start I think so
yeah yes Western a week we'll have
magnets is Carlson play in the grunge
store and there was a review as Michael
korsakovski came on air and explained
that Ding Loren had asked for a little
time out and uh
with that that selection that roster of
players
pretty awesome yeah he was replaced by
Levon aronian
that was quite a replacement their Lavon
yes we take a look at the players for
the rapid and Blitz event they have
Magnus Carlson Wesley so Anish giri mvl
Duda Iranian he'll be this will be his
first Jason event this year Richard
Rapport diac Carol chefchenko also it
will be his I think the Pew yeah yeah
debut and radishek I was about to say uh
three Romanian players as KIRO changes
Federation to really bolster uh what
starting to look like for formidable
Romanian Olympic team as we'll keep an
eye on the one sole remaining game in
our Championship ground as we'll take a
break and see you on the other side
[Music]
thank you
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best join
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
Zagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone as we are in the
championship round of the super bet
chess classic four results in the real
history books now see to be honest
please we have three draws and one win
by the world champion dingley ran with
black pieces What a Beautiful live win
it was for ding in the meanwhile Fabi is
in the
bird seed I guess uh I'm just trying to
think of what it is Fabi with a half a
point lead coming into today's round he
he desperately didn't want to lose the
game which he meant make a nice draw and
he wanted his competitors to all draw
only one player can catch him Anish Gary
is four versus four Queen and Knight
versus Queenie Knight and we think it's
going to be a draw but Anisha ever so
slightly is on the back foot uh he needs
to find a precise series of moves Queen
three more moves yes yeah is the right
way to go yeah and he's been thinking
ever since he made this time control he
got his 30 minute bonus but uh that 30
minutes has been
burn down to what do we have 12 and a
half minutes there it goes so fast yes
it's a little bit worrisome when your
night is on E8 and true kind of Trapped
but not really but you still have to
watch out yeah and your Pawn on F2 is
under attack just as you've described it
uh you know your queen could drop back
that Knight doesn't have that many
squares who knows maybe he's trying to
find ideas to continue the game and hope
for an Apple's mistake because he still
wants to win and do the playoffs with
Bobby true uh so uh in the meantime we
have to defend F2 we have to make sure
our Knight doesn't get trapped
um Queen F3 We Know by the engine is
probably the top move
uh VAR jump in here if I play a move
like pardon me Queen D2 doubtlessly uh
uh mistake I was I was searching for a
move other than Queen F3
now that was not the move I was
searching for Queen Queenie two looks
like a mistake yes it's definitely a not
the best movie I saw inaccuracy now
black can play the move Knight F4 looks
and Anish spent 18 minutes 18 minutes he
probably didn't see something in the
line with the queen F3 but let's take a
look now how nepo can continue here he
does have some chances now after this
move Queenie two so Knight goes to F4
very logical move a Tempo attacking the
queen and now he has to find the only
move already here which is Queen C2 and
that's what he's trying to do keep the
eye on this Pawn on e4 and also control
the D1 Square so there is no check here
and
as I was about to say to protect the
Escape of the night but now he's losing
a pawn by force Queen d8 attacking the
Knight but the main idea is to jump in
on G5 now
so you have to play the move Knight C7
again only move right Queen G5 comes in
now threatening Checkmate on G2 and you
have two options here you can play F3 or
G3 in both cases you're losing a pawn so
if I play G3 yeah if you play G3 just
Knight takes
and what if I attack the Knight King H2
King H2
if you play that I think I just have
Queen H5 right Queen H5 okay and then
Knight G5 and try to make the lights
sorry so I I mean that move Queen C2 was
mystifying for me I'm looking at Queen
C2 VAR and I'm seeing Queen A1 check and
I would be petrified Queen A1 here yeah
King H2 Queen F1 I think there's F3
Knight G 92 threatening Queen G1 made
it's almost made yes I think the only
move is Queen Queen C5
uh sorry I good morning St Louis you
want to go Queen A7 uh your Contra
player yeah I I sorry I I saw 92 and I I
got uh scared if I played Queenie one
here I just have a check and nothing
more yeah if you play Queen E1 here yeah
I'm making Perpetual yeah I also have a
move like Queen E3 there is
yeah it's going to be a prepared but
yeah at first when I you you told me
Queen C2 was the only move I thought oh
let me move my gosh but Queen d8
going for the pawn up uh with Queen G5
yeah yeah we can check the line with F3
F3 is probably a little bit better after
Queen G5 but I think this we might see
this happening this is forced so three
Knight takes H3 check Knight takes H3
and King goes on H2 yeah Knight back and
Knight goes back to F4 yep
and now you're up a pawn and again only
move again for white is to play them
with G3 okay maybe the Knight Queen H5
check King G1 King G1
if you take on F3 we're losing the
Knight on F4 so that's not that good and
now we have to play the move Knight H3
check right King G2 Knight G Knight G5
defense E6 men assist Queen takes and it
looks like you're just about to win and
again only move you have to find here
for white which is Queen F2
these are not easy moves I have to say I
mean I'm a pawn down and I still have to
play in insanely accurate moves just to
stay in the game not a lot of fun for
our Niche absolutely I think he made the
big mistake with this move Queen E2 and
I see some really good look at this
queen C2 instantly so he was ready he
was ready with the only response Queen
C2 but has he missed Queen d8
and we're hearing that loss instead of a
draw will will cost Anish about twenty
one thousand dollars
yikes wow you don't say that uh that's
an expensive uh
draw yeah wow yeah half a point makes
such a big difference wow well you were
telling us a price from from day one of
our broadcast and it's a handsome price
fund but yes tumbling out of second
shared second uh could be very costly
but I'm thinking even the position we're
looking at with the extra power still
should be drawn but yeah because it's
double pawns and if White
and if he missed the same idea that I
missed of Queen C5 I mean we're gonna
have a dragon yeah yeah yes because
again I mean you you're so from Grand
Masters have certain uh patterns that
are branded on their minds and these
patterns of Queen F1 and Knight E2 have
brought us so many successes it's very
easy
to think that this is it yeah to think
you know like you you have this pattern
in your mind yeah that wins that wins
that wins oh Queen F1 and it's just one
thing I don't really understand I mean
uh giri just spent 18 minutes and played
this move and yawn with all the time he
has again pretty he's playing very
quickly this queen A1 Queen F1 and he's
gonna realize after 92 Queen C5 that he
doesn't have anything right they
suddenly no no Checkmate uh G1 is
protected and he did it in the world
championship match it was so costly he
he he rushed certain decisions that had
he just paused
wanted him the world championship title
in this tournament too so many times he
had good positions better opportunities
but again he's just playing quickly he
did not even look for this queen dates
move which which makes a lot of sense
because the Knight is under attack only
eight and we know that with the
configuration of the Knight on F4 we
want to have a queen on G5 that's that's
a very known team to attack on G2 and
that would have guaranteed him extra
Pawn in uh you know long-term Advantage
yeah I'm ashamed to say that I I really
think
you know in his mind Jan was ready to
play Knight E2 and accept resignation
and it's a it's the cold shower that 92
Queen C5 not only is there no
resignation there's no Advantage at all
and you're suddenly making a Perpetual
check with black what a shock that is
oh my does he have any other ideas here
let's say he keeps the Knight on F4 and
maybe goes H5 H4
okay let's have a look H5
I mean uh
what doesn't happen
it's okay H5
um
I don't know my knight is a little bit
weird uh should I be D6 maybe yeah
bringing the Knight home
somehow I mean I understand you can get
your Pawn to H4 Maybe
you know squeeze
uh if I could get my knight to G3 after
that would be great ah okay so here here
you go so let's say I play a bad move I
Knight F7 is right okay let me play a
good move Knight F7 okay now we
understand I've got checkmate
and now we understand I've got Checkmate
but I do have this move Queen
[Music]
right that might be worse if I if we go
into the night end game and I lose a
pawn yeah yeah that would be really uh
annoying so I do have I do have the
defense Queen G1 in such a case
that
it's mystifying right I mean it's okay
for me as a commentator to miss queen C5
but you know he's sitting at the board
and you know he's got to be analyzing so
many variations and just to make a
superficial uh
oh this wins with 40 minutes on the
clock there is really no need to rush
exactly exactly
um what we are criticizing on is uh for
the decision to go Queen A1 and queen F1
when the when the opportunity of Queen
d8
Knight C7
give me the Checkmate and whether you
defend with F3 Knight takes H3 or if you
defend the checkmate with G3 Knight
takes H3 in either case black is a pawn
to the god some massaging some
opportunity uh ahead for the black
player the current position on the other
hand
is like absolute uh now I believe it's
zeros right why does defend defending
everything everything on the first to be
defended on the secondary yeah
wow
VAR
um
explain it to us what happens to a 2800
uh when they miss something like Queen
C5 it just shows the answer it doesn't
it doesn't matter how strong of a play
you are you gotta take your time you're
still still possible to miss something
and that's what we see right now and uh
this is not the first time in this
tournament that Jan has some really good
opportunities and played a bit too quick
I know you mentioned he won two
candidates tournament and this kind of
worked for him yeah in those in those
tournaments where he put a lot of
pressure but uh also players are getting
a little bit more familiar with his
style of play and I think they realize
that you know him having a lot more time
on the clock doesn't necessarily mean
that you know he has you know calculated
everything so he takes a little bit of
chances by playing really quickly here
like in this game he played this this
check and queen F1 where he had the move
uh Queen d8 I would definitely think a
little bit because I find this idea that
Unleashed it with Queen E2 in court
reaching the Knight on F4 Queen C2 a
little bit strange because you are
putting that Knight on a really good
squares and we know the knights on f4 on
F5 they're very strong and uh you know I
would try to look I'm not sure if I
would Define this but I think I would at
least look for this opportunity now in
this position because it looks really
really centralized you have a great
night your queen is well placed and the
Knight is really poorly placed on it and
you want to take advantage of that
because the only reason we can even play
for a win here is because of the poor
position of the Knight on E8 right this
night was anywhere like on F3 B3
anywhere decent yeah there's nothing to
even talk about but here it's really
badly placed and you do have this really
nice idea queen d8 queen I think he just
didn't see it if he would have just
think about it a little bit he would
just see that he's got this Queenie
Queen G5 or like you say he probably
taught Anish blundered I'm just mating
him right no I mean defense did miss
queen d8 queen G5 idea as well because
he won have gun for this yeah he would
not have played Queenie too definitely
Queen F3 I would have definitely seen
Queen d8 because the idea of Queen d8
not necessarily to play Queen G5 but
Queen d8 traps the Knight
fully conclusively absolutely
and
you know you just have to you have to
just say okay then and you don't have
Queen C6 which is important yeah I said
after Queen yeah because now you
actually give a mate with Queen D1 and
92. this is the pattern that Jan is so
familiar with that it's like hardwired
into the grandmaster's minds and they
know the mating patterns patterns
there's Queen F1 and 92 and 92 both I
absolutely agree with that one yeah
so uh yeah so here we were here we were
after uh Queen C2 and Yan immediately
pounce said I know this I learned this
as a Russian Schoolboy and uh just go
after the G2 pawn and Knight E2 oops
Queen C5 so Jan has suddenly realized
that Queen C5
saves white and now is trying to figure
out
oops like do I have an alternative right
once he realizes oh never mind I was
gonna say he can repeat with 92 Knight
F4 make a quick draw but now he wants to
keep testing Anish I guess exactly well
I think you're the culprit you mentioned
H5 yourself right but I didn't like it
you took your move back yeah after 96 I
was like huh
it's important to guys to bring this
Knight into the game 96 and you want to
go Knight F7 of course create some
Contra play so so that way you can force
uh nepo to give the Perpetual especially
because if we trade Queens here I'm not
sure if black is doing okay here we
don't know this is a night ending it
could be a torture yes this night in
game and then suddenly Anish will have a
chance yeah
in this game but uh yeah I think really
young is probably gonna have to repeat
at some point uh 96 is played
and um
next move is Knight F7 just to Target
the
E5 Pawn if you play the move King G8
white can play Queen C8 check just
simply force you to go back on H7 and
then go to
um
can I play a devil's advocate no King G6
no I wanted to do that and then I was
like if white goes 9c4 then I can do 92
there is no more Queen C5 ah clever but
there's 95 check okay but don't don't
give it up
because now you're still able to play
Quincy yeah
I'm playing with fire so yeah I'm not
gonna do this I'm just going to play the
move Queen C5 protect yes protect my
knight and also protect the crucial
Square on G1 we talk about double
attacks but this is double defense
I hate those double defensive uh ideas
hmm okay that was nice Knight D6 on the
board is a yawn starts to think to
himself well is it time that I bail 92
Queen C5 Queen uh C1 with a Perpetual
check in view
yes that would be the simplest way too
you're absolutely right thank you you're
right
that is indeed unless that's why I have
Queen G1 and is that somehow yeah queen
jiban always holds this this okay yeah
but I was trying to force it now I was
trying to avoid the night ending of
force uh uh a Perpetual so that was why
I was going here and then what was I
doing sorry Knight F7 and then Queen
right yes this was the pipette that I
was trying to force because I didn't
want the night ending the straight at
night ending
then with the double the E pawns it's
black I could find myself worse so in
Knight D6
yeah and just looking young
doesn't look so good
excited uh with Queen A1 Queen I
certainly got myself excited too I have
to say I miss queen C5 hook line and
sinker
yeah
it's no more winning ideas left you know
I reminded we did a poll of our audience
before the round to ask them who they
thought was going to win the tournament
and I was critical of the audience I
thought they got they got it wrong
and uh no they had a floppy as a huge
favorite right 63 63 they they nailed it
squarely on the head uh I don't know if
the graphic's still available there but
to bring that graphic up would be
show them
the prescience
of our audience you know who else got it
right Christian and Darius
nobody cares about those guys
they got it right they had Fabi as well
uh Queen E1 by the way uh
by
um nepo I mean he's basically I think
shutting it down and trying to there is
one trick guys please there is one trick
that he's trying to do here Knight F7 so
yeah he's not trying to go 92 and give a
Perpetual yes so Knight F7 in this
position he wants to play the move Queen
E3 Queen what E3 oh wanting to go 92. so
you take the pawn on E5 be a good guy
and I go 92 and the end game is over
yeah because uh if you play let's say
queen D1 to defend I go Queen F4 check
King H1 and then I insert this Knight G3
check first right only then I pick up
the Knight on E5 goddess is winning
of course you don't have to take only
five you can play Queen B1 Maybe
after 23 just okay hold on uh we got
Queenie one hold on I love that blue
Knight E5 Queen pardon me Knight F7
Queen E3 and just Queen B1 yeah here you
have Queen B1 but also you have a move
uh Queen D1 as well here okay to control
the E2 square and uh should be good
any one Queen B one
yeah both moves are both moves are
holding you're looking to you you you're
not being a pawn grubber no Queen F2 you
have Queen G1 now
gotcha
that's a nice trick that is a very uh
outstanding trick Knight E2 threatening
mate
and simultaneously
threatening made on G1 but
simultaneously check to pick up this
Knight
that's a nice trap yeah maybe a vanish
had 30 seconds on the clock he would
fall for it but
uh
boy I really gotta congratulate you for
you you showed depth understanding great
wisdom really uh you're my hero I
followed you yesterday no more no more
well our congratulations to Daris and uh
Christian
uh boy uh I you were in with a shout yes
yeah I mean if it wasn't for a slip up
here early in the tournament yes in one
game against Bobby right MBL would have
been been a contender
yeah uh nicely done guys uh very very
very good it's uh we're winding down our
broadcasts of uh this super bet chess
classic it's I mean these events in
Romania has done let's make it clear
outstanding I mean the audiences have
been fantastic the organization first
class but tournament moves on and just
to remind everybody that the next in the
grand chest tour will be in Warsaw
Poland it will begin Sunday it will be a
rapid and Blitz and it will feature
Magnus Carlson as well as our incredible
lineup of a grantchester participants
Dean Lauren will be taking a leave of
absent from the tour he'll catch up on
the other rapid and Bliss and Lavon
aronian who has always played the grand
chess tour as a player accepting this
year this is the first year the grand
Chester that Livonia Iranian isn't a
featured player and there is the player
roster wow simply wow right uh what a
what a list right I it's funny for me to
look at the rating difference between
the first set and second side yes
because in skill they're not that
different of course Magnus is Magnus but
right and these are rapid ratings yeah
Universal rapid Universal rating system
which includes the Blitz and Rapid
that's the why Magnus is
846 uh Stratosphere yes maybe he'll try
to reach 2900.
it has mentioned it before it's uh as as
a goal funny as he was mentioned he had
been mentioning that as a goal we we in
an interview nepo had said okay my most
immediate goal is get to get back to
2800. so like oh okay uh good luck with
that uh well done
and only eight minutes left here and
what did you call it a 21
000 yes
can I propose a halving of a of the
point however you finish just calculates
correctly next couple of months he's not
gonna need more than 30 seconds on the
clock to finish this game but that's
what it's about accurate calculation
Queen E1 setting up some trappy cheapos
but still Knight F7 I don't think there
could conceivably be a better move
unless he's looking at Knight C4
maybe on a good day hey wait a minute
too right away
you're right you're right I I still need
to make sure I have Queen C5 as an
answer to 92 shoot shoot shoot I was
just about to convince myself that you
know what you know Knight C4 would be a
good move but it's not Knight F7 in that
case Knight F7 is really mandatory and
that happens sometimes when we're in
Long think we start to overthink and
forget the most simplest idea we had in
the position that we have Quincy five
and then you forget about it play 94 and
resign exactly
dope yep how many times does that happen
oh well I thought I saw the Knight was
coming back but I saw it this way yeah
yeah I thought oh my gosh he's going the
wrong the wrong direction that it was
close a little bit of a we were okay he
I but it's still it's like I mean it's
going to the wrong direction yeah I mean
Knight F7 you know you're set up for
Knight G5 check is set up for Knight
takes C5 Knight B5 What attracted him to
the move Knight B5 are
yeah I'm not sure why he played because
I was I was looking at this move at all
I was trying to uh you know attack the
pawn only five to get some Contra play
clear yeah another move that was engine
was okay with was the move a knight B7
that was there 90 B7 here because that
boy seven yeah that gives you the idea
of Queen C5 in a lot of even if you play
Queen E3 that gives you that move Queen
C5 in this position because you're
protecting that square so I think 97 was
okay too after Knight B5 I think Nepal
is getting some chances here I will show
you the key line here okay after Knight
B5 so he can play he has two moves here
you can play the move H4 with some
advantage or he can start with the move
Knight E2 now treating the move Queen G1
so Queen C5 is absolutely only move
up being the mate Queen G3 check okay
King H1 only move and uh you you can
play the move Knight F4 but then there
is uh there is going to be a queen C2 or
a queen C2 idea here
um
so Queenie one check of course you just
have a repetition but you can have this
move Queen F4
okay so and
now you have some ideas with the Knight
G3 as well here so there's some moves
that you really have to play here for a
while which is not not easy to see like
for example Knight C3 loses to Queen C1
check let's say I just play Knight D6
back 96 yes
96 now loses check PNG one king G1 H4
and why is this lost you're threatening
these Queens 13 21 and yeah and you're
not getting uh you're not being able to
get that King H2 Queen G1 setup I think
all right so you're losing a piece here
it looks like so instead of 96 Knight C7
bar
Knight C7 let's take a look at Knight C7
again losing again in some of these
lines you're going to drop Knight again
same idea check right so you play King
G1
Queen D2
just feels like White's coin at night
are out of play yeah it doesn't have a
stable square and this is a big problem
here and um
if you play Queen F2 it's very clear now
I go check and there goes and then I go
H4 securing my knight now creating a
mate on H1 or picking up your knight
again Knight is a big problem and that's
the reason he had to play Knight F7
because Knight on F7 cannot be attacked
with the queen it was also putting
pressure on the E5 Pawn absolutely
absolutely so
um some real chances here we see for uh
for nepo here so let's see here 95 92
Queen C5 let's continue uh because this
is the critical line here King H1 Queen
F4
and uh
what does white need to play here to
defend Queen C2 is the only defensive
move
and now check here
and if you play King G1 again you get
into a trouble here with the move Queen
E3 Queen F2 loses to Queen C1
idea so uh followed by actually sorry
you have to play Queen F2 here because
if you go King H2 I I get this idea
Queen E1 now
with the idea H4 and queen H1
Queen C3 and now Knight comes to D2
King James 25 moves yesterday yeah
any good Grandmaster would have seen it
right away and now H4 and you're in uh
it's sort of a suksamang now you can't
move the Knight Knight uh F1 drops the
queen so yeah you're no I mean this
looks this looks terrible yeah this is
just and he and he's putting uh the
white king under Locker
yeah H4 and now Anish needs to find the
only move that is not losing what
so only move here guys
what is it because Knight C7 is the only
move
Knight C7 I mean
I'd be thinking sorry to say Knight C3
I'd probably be losing the game
to stop Knight E2 I would be
frightened of 92 in Queen G1 made yeah
the problem with this movie is I just
played King G6 and you don't have any
moves I'm Zeus
Queen B2 that allows the move Knight D3
so if Knight C3 you're saying King he's
King G6 and my king can't move my pawns
can't move he's reaching for the night
if I go Queen B2 Knight Knight D3 Knight
D3 and Knight F2 and loses I just played
Knight D6 is this
96 now losers to Knight E2
wow 92 Queen C5
Queen C5 now Queen G3 check King H1 and
this move Queen F4 once again setting up
that same name this Knight is going to
be hanging in a lot of this variations
now so we were getting this position
earlier but black spawn wasn't on H4 and
that makes all the difference in the
world because the Knight on G3 is secure
it's secure so I can wow she's made on
H1 and Ani she's clock
is also showing that the positions that
he's really under so Queen C2 here for
example then we go Knight G3 check
if you go
to G1 that's just me just out of
curiosity if I go King H2 oh it just how
do I get mated because if you take
Knight E4 you're still pinned I don't
take I play Knight F5
and then pick it up again once again we
see the problem in this position with
the Knight on the six constantly hanging
and um yeah somehow Anish couldn't
figure out the complications after that
move Queen E2 he played I think Queen is
big problem if Nepal wins so both world
champion and the Challenger who had
horrible tournament finished with a win
that's remarkable because we I I have
been suggesting for a long time that uh
our producers have been making typos on
the score board with in Challenger and
Champion tied for ninth yes it's been
it's been horrifying and like you just
said uh it would be a remarkable finish
but they both win with black pieces
uh especially in the game where they had
nothing to play for right
because to show that they really are can
um steal so now when it's too figure out
that this idea with Queen F4 is just
winning yeah correct 92 yeah 92 first
and then Queen G3 Queen F4 but to be
fair black has no other ideas so even if
he doesn't know it's winning he will
probably play it because it looks most
natural exactly night eat
he snuck in the moves h
six and H4 yes why do we need 92 can I
play Knight H5 and go to G3 from there
I guess it's just a question of how
forcing is it but Knight G3
um
you set up the Knight on G3 Queen H1
checkmating pattern
and I'm crying uh I got nothing I can do
anything you can't play Queen C5 and
black still needs to do queen G3 check
and queen F4 because in the immediate
Knight G3 allows me to make the
defensive reaction queen that makes it
even worse that both moves are winning
ninth age five or night shaking his head
as he suddenly come to the realization
that oh dear
and well you know it's a funny thing but
the body posture of Anish giri is
feeding
nepo uh when you're when you suddenly
see your opponent emotionally collapsing
at the board
it's it's a the worst guy to play was
Anatoly carpa
because he could be two Rooks down and
he would look a stoically as like you
know everything's proceeding according
to plan and he had the most amazing
poker face he you you there was no
reveal
that's precisely what it did it was like
I'd look across the board and I say dude
I'm beating you and I look and I see his
fave and he just seemed to be
absolutely yeah calm as can be and then
I'd look again and I I'd have my doubts
but when I see my opponent you know like
oh yeah
I got this i got this yeah look uh so
both moves but Knight E2 is 92.
threatens Queen made in one Queen C5
defend the maiden one nothing else to be
done check and just drop the queen back
and say I'm setting up I'm setting up
for Knight G3 and there's no defense and
I
the pain that Anish
a great tournament if you
if you oh it's
it's like entire tournament it was bad
was it yeah you like you failed uh
wow yeah the queen of night cooperation
in this game has been and conversely
White's night has kind of been you know
searching for a role instructive end
game truly
how you should play with Conan Knight
and how you shouldn't play with the
queen at night
learn your roles right
oh my
and yeah nepono does have a lot of time
so he can calculate until the end really
right
it's actually funny that he should now
take his time
is this another
moment where uh Jan splits in worked out
again
you see he keeps getting rewarded for
his quick play at times and just to
remind those of you who may be joining
us late first of all shame on you but
this is how the day has gone so far
right we've had three draws and one
beautiful win by Dinkley ran with the
black pieces and we're expect expecting
another win with the black pieces with
uh nepo against gear and for those of us
is it for those of us all three of us
who had expected a tie break and to see
somebody like either Anish or Wesley
somebody tying with Fabi to uh force a
playoff we we be wrong and let's just
see if we've got some more moves did
play Knight E2 Queen C5 and we just have
to wait and see if he does Queen G3
Queen F4 idea it looks convincing
is that the only winning idea where if
nepo doesn't put his Queen on F4 is
there any other way
so let's see here
um
Queen C5
Queen
oh so there is black and play Queen D2
and if you take Queen E5 yes if you can
make yes on the board yes I will that
Knight F4 forcing only move Queen G5
yeah
threatening mate oh sorry the night is
hanging I missed that never played
Knight G3 and allowed Queen G1
is this still winning what
wow what
oh my God what
seriously
I mean he's playing Knight G3 Queen E1
I like it's a win but what it's not it's
just the draw now just a second hold on
he went 92 Queen C5 all he had to do was
find Queen G3 and queen F4 and that was
winning
okay look he's had an idea yeah four yes
93 threatening made in one he seems very
confident he just walked away from the
board as if I've got this yeah I mean
he's calculated that is he intends now
to play Knight F4 Knight G3 check King
F2 Queen F4
and I gotta say that let's convince it
yeah doesn't it or I mean I would be
convinced
me to find uh Knight B7 here guys come
on and how does it say seven yes 9b7 is
the best move check 933 check King H2
Queen H2 for threatening discovered
picking up and now you play this move
Queen B1
defending the Knight defending the
Knight and if you take Knight takes C4
actually do that one and you're losing a
piece because you're pinned and the
Queen on B1 is well placed because it's
actually defending the Knight and
everything is protected so let's say you
play King H6 now he can go back
King G1
wow and you have your background
protected and your knight is protected
the queen being on B1 makes all the
difference the first rank is safe
even this looks still lost I know I feel
like my poor head hurts to begin with
937 the only move what about Knight B5
for example
uh if you play the move Knight B5 then
uh
much better chances for black again you
don't have that many good moves after
the move 95 so I can just go King G6
first it looks like he's reaching for
Knight B5
how can you tell
it's like you you're driving a car and
the guy in front of you yeah
Knight V7 he found the um oh my word
Knight B7 and again and for sure nepo
has prepared night Shack Queen F4
thinking he's picking up the goodies he
means he missed Queen B1 B1
I feel like
I I'm kind of stunned why Queen B1 why
not Queen D1 what's the difference
okay Knight takes E4 is with the check
and I can I can get away with it but
even after Queen B1 so I can go Knight
F1 double check your only move is King
G1 I can I can flush your king towards
the center
King F2
and
wow yeah I you you you couldn't take
because of the shish kebab I get this
attacking your queen I guess
game's never over until it's over truly
this game has had
three so many times so many turns yeah
at least my goodness my goodness what a
game
jeez it seemed obvious to us that Queen
going to F4 was immediately winning
right but the subtle difference that
allowing Queen B1 then does not win I
mean that's very easy easy easy easy to
miss absolutely
but this was the confounding one
[Music]
when he uh I'm sorry when he acted
actually this isn't the camera yeah
Queenie won a knight F1 it was uh just
the moment before the queen E1 move
Queen C5 was was great
uh pardon me Knight E2 was great Queen
C5 but Knight G3 was the confounding
move at this exact moment he had that
Queen G3 check and then queen of four so
Knight still keeps the G1 occupied so
one Queen cannot come back and there's
no Queen C1 so White Queen just cannot
make it to the first rank in time
precisely that is exactly uh as far had
explained to us but this uh game
position to to understand that the queen
can get to be one
do we think now this will be a draw or
there's be there'll be another moment of
someone blunder yeah we do have Knight
G3 Queen F4
Queen B1 Queen B1
great move by got it now
wow
wow yeah you know this really reminds me
of these games of the world champions
where they're on the back foot you have
them under pressure
and you give them this narrow narrow
narrow window to escape they crawl right
through it right you never get to escape
from their grip they always get you when
they have a winning position and you
have a winning position your Precision
has to be
extraordinarily high and anisha's
climbing through that window of escape
this is just so frustrating Black's
position looks so winning and then you
can find how to win exactly
exactly VAR Express uh your frustrations
because you've had games where you've
absolutely thought I've got my opponent
right where I need them and you made
that one slip absolutely many many times
yes sir especially when I was playing a
lot more competitively yeah I was
playing a lot more games it's it's very
tough and again we learned that you know
you have to just try to be as much as
you can focus until the very end of the
game you know there are probably several
times in this game now yanta the game is
already over mentally you know just I'm
just about to win the game and then
there was some kind of Defense coming
out same thing now we see he missed this
move Queen B1 he thought he's just gonna
take only four next come back on G3 play
the move E4 and easily win the game but
he missed this queen B1 and uh now it
looks like should be a drop but still I
think he's going to try to push hard put
some more problems here that Knight is
still out of place on B7 I see that in a
behind you you put King on H6 and you
were playing with some variations
anything you discovered about this
position that that nepo can do yeah I
was I was trying to see uh what can
black do you know to create a threat
here so after Queen B1 I thought it's
logical to put the King on H6 not on the
background so there are no checks so
King H6 and now only move is King G1
because Knight E4 is already a threat
here and I was trying to see how because
the Knight is still far away so you sort
of defend it with your king and a queen
at the moment so you have a few options
here but Queen D2 looks like the move to
go to here now again you want to maybe
try to bring the Knight back to F4 here
because you no longer have like a
serious threat here on the background
with the queen being on B1 so
he can play King H2 you can play King H2
and now Knight E2 comes in
right and it seems like white is just
waiting here
King H1
and he did play King four and then Queen
G1 comes in
and that move is just ideal because the
Dream from Black's perspective is Queen
B4 which looks like it's a tesuji on the
night but you've got Knight C5 Knight C5
comes up and the Queen on G1 defends G2
defends the Knight on C5 it's the
all-purpose
uh move their best supporting actress
the queen we have couple moves on the
board do we yes we have King H6 and he
immediately played the correct move King
G1 never played Queen D2
so now white just needs to go back King
H2 right King H2 is not the only move
you can also play Queen A1 in this
position
um A1 I'd be afraid to do that and live
my life yeah yes yes so that's why
probably King H2 will be the the human
best move to play here and Anish needs
to make sure he has some time left on a
clock for the you know if Jan comes up
with some new ideas so at least he has a
few minutes to figure out uh you know
and um he's been playing quite fast last
couple of months so he gained some time
and now has seven and a half minutes
versus youngs for 10 minutes
um in a replay we uh just an instant a
moment ago there seems to have been a
reaction and
uh Anisha apologize yeah we don't know
what happened yeah
maybe he was too close on the board or
something the the
the thing that most often happens is for
some reason you start shaking your leg
if you have your elbow on the table oh
yes and your legs start shaking table
you know there's a there's a
reverberation through and yeah you see
the foot yes you see the foot of Anish
the right foot a little shaky shaky and
then the table and yeah yeah I think
that was what uh it was a by the way
Anish did a a chessable course
where he did a commercial for the
chessable course and there he was in his
office
Manning the the the computer making the
moves and there's the camera showing you
know a niche the professional diligently
at work and then the camera pans down to
his feet and his little son is riding on
his foot as our Niche is lifting here
and he said he's so happy you know
giggling so Anish was multitasking he
multitasking yeah as Daddy and
professional
um
tricks VAR
tricks
what's going on can nepo set up
something for
I mean I'm still still there are some
tricks again this queen and Knight
coordination is very tricky you got that
pawn on H4 that is giving you some
options
with accurate play it should be a draw
but the question is can you play so
accurately with six minutes on a clock
it's not easy because the Knight is too
far away and uh you know it's it's it's
you always have to look for ideas here
so he just played the move Knight E2
here and here the best move here is just
to move the king back to H1 right
just play Queen F4 and go back to that
setup
trying to get the same setup so okay
Queen F4 here yes yeah
uh you can but then um
but if you play Knight G3 I have King E2
so it's like there's no particular
threat no threat here and then uh here
you can play Maybe Queenie one 98 or
Queenie one actually makes sense yeah
so if you're playing Knight G3 now I
feel really good here because I feel
like I cut off the square so far
95 93 into the game so this would be
complete equality here a little bit of a
relief for white so King H1 is an
important move because you don't want to
be sitting on the queen F4 check all the
time so this is a this is the most
precise defense
um in this position Queen A1 is also
okay but again then you're living your
knight unprotected so it's it's not as
good here VAR completely ridiculous idea
and over the top egregious idea King H1
if you don't mind sure King H1
King G5 I mean it was like completely
hilarious King F4 King James even if we
get the king oh you want to go to F2 F2
and if I try to bring my knight in 1944
King F4 I'm gonna lose oh wait this is
it's okay it's okay
take King G3
I mean a good king walk you know you got
to stretch the legs the Fabio would get
nervous here because now black can lose
F2 yeah like something like this you
don't oh that wouldn't be egregious yeah
yeah yeah that would be it's still a
draw here it's fun no way I would be
afraid if I was white I had to be a
friend with both characters
and somehow it's still equal here I
guess remarkable yeah
King H1 he was hovering over the king
yeah it doesn't have any other moves so
King H1 would be the best defense here
he has got four minutes on the clock-ish
we'll see if Nepal will go all the way
with the King a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but uh you know it's
just
uh giving it a shot yes why not yeah
well actually now that I think about it
I could have gone to E3
so uh King H1 we think is the best King
G5 we think that Knight here is the best
right King here we think Knight takes is
the best oh no he he won for Queen A1
changed his mind oh which was a second
okay move was it yeah okay
yeah it was a very computer move we kind
of felt like leaving the night
unprotected
Arbiter delivering score sheets probably
I don't know yeah
actually there was a time when we had
these uh time controls of 40 moves in
two and a half hours one hour for 16
moves thereafter
and so we have these score sheets that
were 40 moves long and then we had
the secondary score sheet and sometimes
I was upset when I usually was ahead off
in the clock the Arbiter would come and
bring the second score sheet as if to
indicate to my opponent you've made the
time controlled it's like dude could you
like leaving Maloney's let him suffer
Queen A1 VAR uh jump in
that move we we kind of shied away from
but I'm reassured that it it's perfectly
okay it's okay but now black should play
the move Knight F4 threatening made on
G2
has to come back now Queen has to come
back you have a move
um you have both moves Queen F1 or queen
G1 okay so let's see if you play the
move Queen F1 okay just so you're not
too passive here on F1 and here there's
this idea Queen before now putting
pressure on the Knight which is
something that frightened you don't want
to play Queen A6 now because then after
the move Queen B2 okay you are in
trouble your queen is overworked you
can't really go back defend G2 because
you're gonna drop the Knight so this
will be losing right so you can't play
Queen A6 you'll still have some problems
with your knight here now you have to
find the very the only move Knight d8
yeah this is incredible Queen D4 now
attacking the Knight
C6
C5 now the same problem if you play the
move Queen A6 I can play Queen C2
forcing you to come back and then I pick
up your knight so the very only move now
guys Knight B8 wow and now it's gonna be
safe on A6 is that the idea it has some
study like qualities to it I mean it it
at first blush
Queen F4 check we have included so we
didn't have a knight F4 we have queen of
four and Knight G3 I'm sure King G1 we
transposed to the same position
or like we had this position before
right we need to check and uh our Niche
happy to to grab some extra minutes on
the clock because all of his moves were
forced he had no choice
it's the idea that young
that's no fair I was going to ask the
same question I had that idea first I
don't know why he didn't try this idea
because I find it very hard for white to
move this Knight like that and putting
the knife on the floor would it make
sense in my opinion here
um so at the moment E5 is hanging
and queen F4
forces King
G1
so right now 92 doesn't achieve anything
right I can play Just 21.
yeah you're right pardon me this mate
sorry blindness uh good morning St Louis
Knight E2 92 Queen E1 already maybe
that's where he wants to go King G5 but
okay okay I mean hard to untangle from
this queen and Knight on the e-file now
though but somehow I'm making
incremental progress if I can go check
and check and
geez I don't know unwind my
I want now to put my king on F4
I'll tricky but
now Knight C5 Knight C5 it's just
completely fine now in that position
Knight C5 after Queen E1 yeah okay so it
was 92 92 21. Queen is really well
placed only one here because it's
defending a lot of the dark squares and
the G3 skirt so King G5 and just we're
looking at King G5 and sorry immediately
play tonight C5 with a tempo as well
as well should be completely fine here
wow
you might need to repeat now Queen F4
Queen E3 yeah you might need to repeat
here
wow
first of all I mean kudos to Anish for
finding out an entire
uh
okay of uh really yeah figuring out that
night on B7 is the best yes
what queen went to A1 and uh
doing it all with just a few minutes on
his clock
crazy crazy good these guys are crazy
good
yes and um
apple looks frustrated like there should
be something right why am I not saying
it
and it's another thing during the game
you're not sure if your position is
winning or if it's actually a draw right
so you think you're just missing
something you're not saying something
and it's very frustrating well again we
have certain patterns uh Grandmasters
have that are hardwired into our minds
one pattern is the Knight is on G3 and
the pawn is on H4 and we're always
securing checkmates so we've come to
respect that pattern as winning another
pattern we have hardwired is a knight on
F3 and upon on G4 so that we're always
having these checkmates and background
mates on G1 and have what have you so
it's like
we think that those patterns are always
winners and sometimes as we discover
like with the queen going to C1 it's C5
and defending G1 it's not always the
case of a certain victory
but it's easy to be you know thinking
that oh I've got this and like you said
frustrated
yeah and uh now I we've learned Queen
can be an amazing Defender just putting
the Quinn on the first rank saves the
game yeah
yeah but if we go way back earlier uh it
was an easier draw for Anish but he made
some wrong moves with the Knight exactly
and that's why black had this one second
chance to win his uh napo's chance has
flared anew
by the way you were telling that for
Anish giri the difference between a win
and a pardon me a a draw and a loss was
21 000. obviously if he wins it'd be
even greater because look far greater he
would be tied for first
and if he could win the whole tournament
right for for Napo and ding or on this
terrible three three points they kind of
hit a little bit of a trampoline
uh by the way we just saw a little Queen
B6 Queen B6 no I was not expecting that
but
yeah now this gives away I think the
whole you know whatever Advantage you
had left here now Queen C1 check and now
you finally bring that Knight to good
Square on side
now you can breathe you're like okay I'm
okay now for sure fine I don't see five
and perhaps we did I just hear a cry of
no
from Fabi
because if you go I don't care King H7
and I go Knight C5 it's a there's an
outside conceivable chance black has to
really try to lose this right visibility
yeah you got to work on it you know you
got to work hard but how many chess
players kind of blunder any time yes yes
there is no position that's so bad that
it can't be won by a blender from the
opponent
a big blender huge a massive blender
I wait please see one check on the board
just in time to rescue the night that
otherwise would seem
prepped
yeah I wanna I think it was from a U.S
Championship it was a game between
um
Larry Evans and Sammy rashevsky Sammy
was completely completely completely
winning
like dead dead dead dead in fact he was
so winning
that Larry had no moves with his King
which is kind of a Prelude to what I was
about to suggest he walked into a stale
he allowed a stalemate from you know a
massively over killing position so yeah
blunders are always and Knight C5 on the
board
wow what is it you just almost have this
this feeling of really yes as this night
is about to get back into some defensive
I don't know why it's Queen can come to
G5 next move threatening H4
yeah no on a good day you're absolutely
right my gosh we make a mistake King H7
we just Queen G5 gift to me then you
have to defend the queen end game yeah
that's probably an easy draw but well
yeah yeah yeah yeah but still oh no
actually if you take on C5
still should be a draw but
who wants this this is no guarantees
this is where Fabi is crying no
no don't don't play King h8 should black
just play King G6 to not let white play
Queen G5
uh I'm not sure because
if we're allowing black wants to draw he
can just go Knight F1 here right
sorry for a moment there I was getting
myself in a tangle uh thinking about
Knight D7 and
95.7 Queen D6 yes or queen D4 is where
yeah and again not not and I shouldn't
be going in those directions but
um
VAR
it could be an engine uh estimate please
if you don't mind it's Anish now it's
completely fine and like is in zero
zeros or zero zero zero completely this
is the moment where Jan needs to pull
the brakes you know and he didn't pull
the brakes he didn't pull the brakes
92 okay definitely avoided Queen G5
which is the good news but queen queen
E1 queen queen C4 Queen C4 queen queen
or maybe Knight D4
uh Queen you mentioned Queen E1
well then I guess that's the queen
ending with four versus four you're not
winning H4 but uh
can I just
investigate let me have a quick quick
quick see he did go Queenie one if Queen
C4 there was a knight F4 so that's
probably why Amish wants to avoid that
yeah I think they're about now uh
oh no pardon me Knight E2 Queen E1 is on
the board sorry
93 back so offering a repetition
and after night here
24 okay and again I just feel I'm in a
in a situation where he's a draw is the
most likely but
aren't I kind of threatening Knight H1
it's like I would at this point why it's
not risking anything absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing yeah he can try to
bring the Knight also on G4 which will
be very well placed also on T3 Knight F2
and G4 and uh guys special broadcast may
go a lot longer here yes and their
anisha's
what's my risk ratio reward here for
playing on the night on D3
and again the assessment is zeros but
yeah yeah wouldn't we prefer to be white
just however a little bit you know well
Jan needs to bring this Knight to F4 now
so he needs to play Queen D4 okay uh
centralizes Queen Knight F2 okay and try
to put this Knight on F4 so he can try
to have a contra play so queen queen 85.
and I don't know guys but uh the the the
the drama continues
oops sorry I I've got to refresh my
board apologies I will catch up with the
players very very shortly so we have
Knight G3
it's nice one no I think they're going
to repeat I don't see how
I can try
just a moment just a moment right each
one yeah
Knight H1
again if you take I have a switch and
Zoo sure
maybe I'll just go an id2 check which is
forced and then you're gonna have to go
GTA five yes
okay okay just saying
yeah I think I think the players are
putting us out of uh our mercy and wow
both players feel completely exhausted
maybe exalting in their exhaustion
there is one player who is very happy
now guys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
popping a champagne I believe and our
congratulations to Fabiano yes indeed
with clear first our congratulations to
ourselves for having survived such an
early morning wake up
and here's our champion uh standings
and our champion sorry all right Fabiano
caruana winning the Super Bad chess
class again winning hundred thousand
dollars if you need any help spending
your money Bobby you got my number
nice uh congratulations and the rest of
the standings actually thank you
second uh Wesley Richie
yes all picking up nice paychecks 42 750
a piece yeah and uh Maxi Michelle grab
and yeah Kristoff to do that share in
19750 having scored 50 in the tournament
uh I don't think this is updated because
I think NEPA also had the three points
so the last three are not accurate but
okay yeah okay yes exactly yeah because
ding Loren will jump up uh with four
I'm glad the event is over for ourselves
but uh boy that last that last game that
that was something else bar yeah that
could have easily added lots of turns
lots of turns and unpredictable right
twists and turns yeah
absolutely but finally we have a winner
and it was a very exciting very exciting
to see and Fabi I think played the best
of all he was the more stable player and
he got the plus two and actually could
have had more remember round one he was
winning against daak so he could have
easily had plus three score and another
missed opportunity I just remember
against alireza exactly that was the big
one plastery was very easy he could have
had in this tournament plus four you
know if he could get everything you know
the maximum so I think he played the
best and he definitely deserved to win
this tournament so big congratulations
to Fabiano caruana exactly well I don't
have a list I really liked to make a
shout out to so many people for making
our stay so comfortable and possible at
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
Center all the good folks that take care
of us
yeah people don't realize how many
people work behind the scenes absolutely
spectrum and Silverback video video for
all the production efforts we you saw
maybe one glitch or two as far as the
broadcast was concerned but a lot of
people working really really hard to
make sure it all goes very seamlessly
and
uh shout out to our colleague darusha
who manned your position
uh of our uh excellently maybe
absolutely maybe too good you know uh at
keeping us on our toes making and making
sure that we were all very happy and of
course to of course Joey Bray who
organizes everything and yeah just Dr
Jeannie singfield rexingfield for all of
this support uh World Chess Hall of Fame
across the street I know you're going to
do a translation later this afternoon uh
VAR uh for their exhibit so say thank
you to San Luis club for giving me a
chance to try this new job right rookie
what do you think uh you your player
commentator
I like both
and let's jump to uh Bucharest Romania
with Michael korsakovski and uh trophy
giving
after 10 days of a grueling chess here
in Bucharest Romania we are finally
ready to Crown a champion we are joined
by Michael kodarkovsky the executive
director of the grand Chester and
Augusta drages the superbet foundation
president and of course our champion
Fabiano caruana Michael I'm going to
give you the first word thank you
Christian it is exciting that our
American Grandmaster first time ever won
uh
Romania classic championship
and uh Fabio was winning many
tournaments in his career and this one
is definitely uh would be one of the
most memorable I believe and I would
like to congratulate him on on this
result and hopefully he will continue
the same path and will be able to win
the whole tour
thank you
Fabi congratulations thank you for
coming here and uh thank you for being
so so strong and full of energy you take
the lead and you continue till the till
the final price we are happy to have you
here and we hope next year we will come
again thank you Michael thank you
Christy for all what you does here
please allow me to offer you this trophy
is uh yours thank you congratulations
and I think we have one more thing
perhaps for Fabiano Yes actually uh here
are the money
[Laughter]
and I want to say a special thanks for
our executive director of superbet
foundation Christy your Giza is nice to
hear he was taking care about everything
that all goes as should be
congratulations again now I hope for you
and Fabi uh how are you feeling right
now this is a big victory for you you've
never wanted here in Bucharest how are
you feeling yeah it's a great feeling uh
everything went perfectly today I mean
the tournament uh I think went as well
as I could have hoped for there were
some moments that I wish had gone a
little bit better but it was great to be
here I mean the organization was
fantastic it was great to be back in
Bucharest for now the sixth time four
times for the branches tour events and
uh you know always a nice nice city to
visit and I'm glad that I could also win
for the first time here if you could
pinpoint the exact moment where you felt
like you could win this tournament what
would that moment be
uh well about five minutes ago I was
told that that I won the tournament uh
yeah I guess my my game against Yan is
the is the moment that I would probably
pick out but it feels like it was a bit
of an anti-climax because I should have
maybe converted against uh against
alireza to to really feel like I I
deserved the victory fully and I got
just like some fortune in the last two
days at Ali Reza
um lost against I can see on Kristoff
and also today that the whole chasing
pack but uh I survived a difficult game
today against against Richie so overall
it was
um it was good probably you have so many
fans around the world here in Romania as
well you were swarmed uh by kids wanting
your autograph every single time you
were coming out from that playing hole
do you have anything to say to your fans
yeah it's great that you know I've
noticed the last few years a lot more
people are getting into chess I really
feel the energy in a lot of cities not I
mean in Bucharest I really felt it like
there's so many fans here but uh but in
other places as well I feel like there's
a lot of Chess fans
um and you know it's a it's an
international game there's people
watching from all over the world which
is great and
um it's it's a nice feeling that people
really to enjoy watching my chest and
also the chess of my colleagues and uh
that events like this one and other
events in the grantchester are you know
like giving giving chess back to the
public Fabi once again congratulations
you are the champion of the 2023
Superbad chess classic
guys back to you from here in Bucharest
Romania for the last time back to Union
studio in St Louis thank you Christian
and again our congratulations to Fabi
I'm sure you guys are going to have a a
wonderful party and a closing ceremony
in Bucharest to close the curtain on
what has been a great opening event for
the grand Chester fantastic event
absolutely he's lucky to have the front
row seat yes
and let's go through our roster players
count counting down in 10th Place
bhaktan Daniel diet from Romania ten
thousand five hundred dollars
in Ninth Place
representing fide winning thirteen
thousand dollars
and our new world champion Dean
clearance finishing in the eighth place
taking home sixteen thousand dollars a
three thousand dollar bonus over where
he was but boy that Victory today sure
felt good
our congratulations to our reigning
world champion and I share in sixth
place from Poland young Crystal of Duda
taking home
19750. with that win over alireza is
certainly feeling better and nviel also
sharing sixth place uh
taking home same amount
now the people who got A plus score
right uh sharing second third fourth and
fifth uh right Richard rapper from
Romania taking home 42 750. a quiet plus
one Noah's Richard but uh very deserving
undefeated and anishkiri from
Netherlands also taking home same price
also uh very uh uh deserving undefeated
right with that amazing win against the
world champion
undefeated undefeated uh also shared in
second place and then of course the
champion uh plus two no we still have
one more
second place not undefeated in fact I
literacy was the most he was the most
dynamic player suffering two losses he
wins besides Bobby he was the other
player closest to the first place
exactly with his three win scores now of
course our champion Fabiano caruana
taking home hundred thousand dollars
again our congratulations to that be
very very deserving indeed uh what a
tournament has been VAR it's been our
pleasure uh to be working with you but
before we congratulate one another for
surviving yeah we do have a coming up
next right we have super better hidden
blades in Poland starting May 21st
through 26 and we will have world number
one Magnus Carlson joining the tour
with us I enjoying with Magnus as well
event number two in the grand chess tour
now comes a time to save a version
congratulations to you uh your first
time that we've been working that our
first time that we got a chance to work
together as broadcasting and it was a
lot of fun thank you thank you Yasser I
really enjoy working with you guys and
this was a really good opportunity and
really like doing this and looking
forward to the next event we're going to
be doing it starting on Sunday the super
bet in Warsaw Poland and congratulations
to Fabiano on winning clear first he
definitely played the best chess in my
opinion and deserve it they won the
tournament so it was a lot of fun
working with you guys thanks thank you
and the question lingers what what do
you prefer playing
commentator player commentator champion
of the United States commentator come on
come on I like them both oh yeah yes I
want to keep doing both so you're going
to give be back yes I'm excited to say
I'll be back later this week on Sunday
with my brilliant countless cancer by
the way thank you so much for teaching
me how to do this job and you were
natural get out of here I did nothing I
had so much fun working with you you're
going to join us not only for uh Warsaw
but also for the Cairns cup yes in June
wow very excited okay wonderful to have
you that's a wonderful wonderful
wonderful thank you thank you everybody
thank you for joining us tell your
friends where you're hanging out Bring
Your Tweets and uh we really really
enjoyed uh broadcasting now we're gonna
go do a face plant and thank you for
watching thank you for joining us every
day and the biggest thank you to the
players for giving us such exciting
games yeah for us to commentate
goodbye everyone goodbye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited